Hey guys, I'm just, I'm coming at you a little, a little early, and I, excuse me, I'm super excited for you to hear the show, so let's rock and roll, let's smart-less. Smart-less, smart-less, smart-less. I did sweat, then I showered. You sweat and then you showered. So your hair is mixed of sweat, of sweat and sweat. No, no, no. I showered all the sweat out.
嘿，各位，我，我有点，有点提前上线了，然后我，不好意思，我超级激动想让你们听到这个节目，所以让我们摇滚起来，让我们聪明又无知。聪明又无知，聪明又无知，聪明又无知。我出汗了，然后洗了个澡。你出汗了，然后洗了个澡。所以你的头发是汗水、汗水和汗水的混合物。不，不，不。我把所有的汗都洗掉了。
You have just shampooed hair that you're enjoying. Can I now tell Will my next story or no? I want to get into your next story, but hang on a second, Jason. Did you, God so many questions, did you, do you shampoo every day? I don't, actually I just lied to you, I did not shampoo today. Wow. Yeah, you sweaty, that's all sweat. I will not shampoo, but once a week, because, you know, as most, most smart, well-groomed
你现在的头发刚洗过香波，你很享受。我现在可以把我的下一个故事讲给威尔听吗，还是不行？我想听你的下一个故事，但等一下，杰森。你，天哪，有这么多问题，你，你每天都用洗发水吗？其实我没有，我刚才对你撒谎了，我今天没有用洗发水。哇。对，你满头大汗，那全是汗。我不用洗发水，但一周用一次，因为，你知道的，正如大多数，大多数聪明、仪容整洁的
listeners will attest to, you will get fluffy, flyaway hair if you shampoo every day. You got to keep it a little- You think most of our listeners will get it. No, no, most of them will get it. But then the opposite is oily, gross. That gives you a handsome clumping, okay, it's the name of my new autobiography. New autobiography. Sean, do you- Handsome clumping. Not to be confused with handsome humping, Sean's three part- Yeah, three part series.
听众所证明的，如果你每天都用洗发水，你的头发会变得蓬松、乱飞。你得保持一点——你觉得我们大多数听众都能理解。不，不，大多数人都能理解。但反过来就会油腻、恶心。那会让你有一种帅气的结块，好吧，这是我的新自传的名字。新自传。肖恩，你——帅气的结块。不要和帅气的驼背混淆了，肖恩的三部曲——对，三部曲。
Three, there's only three parts. Did you, Sean, did you, how often do you shampoo? I shampoo every other day. Really? Every other day. Did you condition to? Oh wait, I can answer that. Never, ever, never.
三部，只有三部。你，肖恩，你，你多久洗一次头？我每隔一天洗一次头。真的吗？每隔一天。你也用护发素吗？哦等等，我可以回答这个。从来没有，永远没有，从来没有。
Oh. How come you don't use any hair product? Me? Yes. Flyaway, uncontrollable, 1983 feathered- That's my personality, just flyaway and- Why don't you put like a little bit of even mousse? When I see you guys- Even mousse would work. The old mousse.
哦。你怎么不用任何发胶？我吗？对。飞扬的、不听话的、1983年风格的羽毛状——那就是我的性格，总是飞扬，然后——你为什么不稍微抹一点点摩丝呢？当我看到你们的时候——抹一点摩丝也会管用。老式摩丝。
No, when I see you guys on Sunday, a lot of times I'll, I'll throw some, some poopy stuff in there. I don't, I don't see it. You need more. Why don't you try Jen's stuff that Jason did the commercial for? I did. Lola Vee. You're talking about Lola Vee?
不，当我星期天看到你们的时候，很多时候我会，我会往里面扔一些，一些黏糊糊的东西。我没，我没看到。你需要更多。你为什么不试试杰森做过广告的詹的产品呢？我试过了。Lola Vee。你是说Lola Vee吗？
I did. Lola Vee? I did. That you did Amanda's shot. It was not intended to be commercial, unlike Sean's, Sean tried to come over the top with his and he succeeded. Have you enjoyed that yet, Will? No.
我试过了。Lola Vee？我试过了。你拍了阿曼达的那个。那本来不是广告，不像肖恩的，肖恩试图用他的压倒一切，而且他成功了。威尔，你享受过那个了吗？没有。
Did he do one for her too? Did you not see Sean's shower masterpiece? No. Oh, for Jen's products? Oh my God. Yeah. And Scotty shot it and cut it together. In two seconds.
他也为她拍了一个吗？你没看肖恩的淋浴杰作吗？没有。哦，为了詹的产品？天哪。是的。然后斯科蒂拍摄并剪辑在一起。在两秒钟内。
And it's probably online somewhere. No. I don't think it went anywhere. Don't, Sean, don't pull it up. Please don't pull it up. Why not? Probably have a respectable guest that is doubting or questioning their decision at this point. Why don't you just air it on the TV behind you, you know, so that, because you've already
而且它可能在网上的某个地方。没有。我觉得它没流传到哪里去。别，肖恩，别把它搜出来。请别把它搜出来。为什么不呢？可能会有一个受人尊敬的嘉宾在这个时候产生怀疑或对他们的决定产生质疑。你为什么不把它在你身后的电视上播放出来，你知道的，因为你已经
seen it. Wait, where is it? Who knows? You know, I mean, I guess we'll find it one day. Sean. Shoot. I'm looking for it. Obviously.
看过了。等等，它在哪？谁知道呢？你知道的，我是说，我想总有一天我们会找到它的。肖恩。哎。我在找它。显然。
All right. Sean, what have you done with your break? Listener, we did an earlier record and now we're doing a later record and it's been lunch. It's a two for a day. A lunch window here in Los Angeles. No. Don't tell, we'll tell you what you ate.
好了。肖恩，你休息的时候做了什么？听众朋友们，我们之前录了一期，现在正在录后一期，刚好是午饭时间。这是“一天两更”。洛杉矶的一个午餐时间窗口。不。别说，我们会告诉你你吃了什么。
I ate three donuts. Did you really? And a glass of milk. And that's what I had for lunch. Do you usually eat donuts or just whatever the fuck happens to be on the plate? Yum-yums from Yum-yums. Hello? Hello?
我吃了三个甜甜圈。真的吗？还有一杯牛奶。这就是我的午餐。你平时吃甜甜圈，还是随便吃盘子里碰巧有什么的东西？Yum-yums的Yum-yums。喂？喂？
Don't say, don't say, from Yum-yums as if we're supposed to know that. Yum-yums. You're talking about the spot up the street on the corner of Vine and Melrose where they had scored die back at. How do you know that? How do you know that? Wow. I went in my pajamas.
别说，别说，来自Yum-yums，搞得我们好像应该知道那是什么似的。Yum-yums。你说的是街头那家店，在维恩街和梅尔罗斯街的拐角处，他们以前在那里——你怎么知道的？你怎么知道的？哇。我穿着睡衣去的。
I was still in my pajamas and slippers. I walked right in there. Sean, why, why, why do you eat donuts, especially for lunch? For lunch. So good. I was really hungry because I didn't have a big breakfast. And so I was like, you know, when you crave carbs for breakfast, I had like a cup of tea and like a muffin.
我当时还穿着睡衣和拖鞋。我直接走进去了。肖恩，为什么，为什么，为什么你要吃甜甜圈，特别是当午餐吃？当午餐。太好吃了。我当时真的很饿，因为我没吃一顿丰盛的早餐。所以我想，你知道的，当你早餐想吃碳水化合物时，我喝了一杯茶，吃了一个松饼。
Okay. So just keeping score today. So you had a muffin and three donuts. Does your colon ever jump up through your esophagus out your mouth and just square up, look you in the eye and say, what is your fucking problem? What are you doing to me? No, it climbs up, comes out of my mouth and looks me in the eye and says, thank you. Do you just roll into a chin chin now and you go down, you go to a table level with
好吧。所以今天记一下分。你吃了一个松饼和三个甜甜圈。你的结肠有没有突然从食道里跳出来，从嘴里钻出来，然后摆好架势，直视着你的眼睛说：“你他妈到底有什么毛病？你对我都做了些什么？”没有，它爬上来，从我嘴里钻出来，直视着我的眼睛说：“谢谢你。”你现在是不是直接滚进一个下巴的高度，然后你走过去，走到一个桌子边，桌子与
your mouth at the end of the table and they just shovel food into it. You must be busy this time with all the Santa work you're doing, right? How many callbacks did you have for the Grove this year? By the way, we can, we can say because it's on the air obviously already that, you know, the Sean playing Santa in the murderville holiday special was tremendous. Oh, that's right. You do. So required for that.
你的嘴在桌子边缘齐平，他们就把食物铲进你嘴里？你这段时间一定很忙，因为你做了那么多圣诞老人的工作，对吧？今年格罗夫购物中心找你试镜了多少次？顺便说一句，我们可以，我们可以说，因为这显然已经在广播里播出了，你知道的，肖恩在《穆德维尔》假日特辑中扮演圣诞老人演得太棒了。哦，对的。你确实。为此需要。
Sean was so happy because he was like, I don't have to memorize any lines. I know any lines. I can just sit there. It's just dead. It was really funny actually. I am hearing some folks are enjoying that trailer, that teaser, Will. Well, we got a new trailer. Well, this shows, you know, as you know, it's already out.
肖恩太高兴了，因为他当时想：“我不用背任何台词。我不用背任何台词。我只要坐在那里就行了。它就像个死物。”其实挺搞笑的。我听说有些人挺喜欢那个预告片的，那个宣传片，威尔。我们有个新预告片。这个节目，如你所知，你知道的，已经播出了。
Yes. Now with the airing of this podcast. But I tell you what, I tell you what, it's going to be timeless just like, just like our guest today. Yeah, speaking of your guests, I have something caught in my teeth and I have floss with me and I'm wondering if this is a guest. So go ahead and floss. Go ahead and floss.
是的。随着这期播客的播出。但我告诉你，我告诉你，它会像经典一样永不过时，就像，就像我们今天的嘉宾一样。对了，说到你的嘉宾，我牙齿里卡了点东西，我随身带了牙线，我在想这会不会是嘉宾。所以去用牙线吧。去用牙线吧。
Can I floss during the intro? Because when you see that, because they're going to give you shit for it. They will. Go ahead, Sean. Yeah. Go ahead, Sean. Whatever you say. I have to tell you my, my neck.
我能在开场白的时候用牙线吗？因为当你看到那个时，因为他们会因此而数落你的。他们会的。去吧，肖恩。对。去吧，肖恩。随便你说什么。我得告诉你我的，我的脖子。
You've been talking about the next story. Across two episodes. I know. It better be good. Go. Okay, Sean. Go quickly. Let's go.
你一直在说下一个故事。跨越了两集。我知道。最好是个好故事。开始吧。好吧，肖恩。快点。我们开始吧。
I'm going to floss during it. No, no, it's too long. You know? Okay. Because this person likes stories. They like telling stories. Okay. You know, Jason.
我打算在期间用牙线。不，不，太长了。你知道吗？好吧。因为这个人喜欢故事。他们喜欢讲故事。好吧。你知道的，杰森。
They're okay. I'm going to let you listen to the floss. No, but the camera's on the crotch. They're not watching and they were just listening. God, this is, this is like a nightmare. This is just what I do when I floss. That is so disgusting. Our guest is somebody, this is what an intro.
他们还好。我要让你们听听用牙线的动静。不，但是镜头对着胯部。他们没在看，他们只是在听。天哪，这简直是，这简直是一场噩梦。这就是我用牙线时做的事。太恶心了。我们的嘉宾是一个人，这算什么开场白。
Our guest is somebody who is not your run on the mill. This is somebody who does a lot of different things. Somebody that we all know, some of us better than others. We've been friends with for a long time. This person is, gets to do all sorts of different stuff. They're not just stuck in an office. Although there was a time when he was stuck in an office for many years on TV. I can't say too much because you know who it's got to be because it's Krasinski.
我们的嘉宾是一个绝非平庸的人。这是一个做过很多不同事情的人。一个我们都认识的人，有的人比其他人更熟悉。我们和他做很久的朋友了。这个人，有机会做各种各样不同的事情。他们不只是被困在办公室里。尽管曾有一段时间，他在电视上被困在办公室里很多年了。我不能说太多，因为你知道这一定是谁，因为他是卡拉辛斯基。
Yes. Yay. Yes. Oh, fire please. And you're in the bedroom. Oh, you're in your own bedroom. This is my own, oh, sorry about that. Yeah, I mean, that's fine.
是的。耶。是的。哦，请开火。你在卧室里。哦，你在你自己的卧室里。这是我自己的，哦，不好意思。是的，我是说，没关系。
John, what, let's get into it here. Who's fault is this? I'm just happy to be here before the bicentennial. You know what I mean? Just before the 200th guest. It's outrageous that Emily was here before you, Will. Well, they were supposed to be back to back days and it got moved a few times because of schedule of everybody, a bunch of you, because John one time and you and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
约翰，什么，我们切入正题吧。这是谁的错？我只是很高兴能在两百周年庆典之前来到这里。你知道我的意思吗？就在第200位嘉宾到来之前。艾米莉比你先来，这太离谱了，威尔。嗯，他们本来应该是背靠背两天的，由于大家的档期问题改了好几次，你们中的很多人，因为约翰有一次，还有你，巴拉巴拉巴拉巴拉。
So it was supposed to be, so literally when Emily was on and you're, and we're like, we got to get John on and I'm just like, just keep it straight, because he was supposed to be on the next day. Oh, well, I was holding the boom for, so I heard the whole thing. Yeah, so he was there the entire time. Were you really there when we were interviewing? Yeah, and he had a bounce, and he had a bounce card too. Hollywood had a bounce card. Wow.
所以本来应该是，所以字面意思上，当艾米莉来的时候，你，我们就在想，我们得把约翰请来，我当时就想，保持原样，因为他本来应该第二天来的。哦，好吧，我当时在举挑杆，所以整个过程我都听到了。是的，所以他从头到尾都在那儿。我们采访的时候你真的在那儿吗？对，他还有一个反光板，他还有一个反光板呢。好莱坞有一个反光板。哇。
It was just Hollywood-ing. Boom's in. Boom's in. Hollywood myself. John. Hollywood. All right. Listener, I apologize up top.
这就是好莱坞式的作风。挑杆进。挑杆进。我自己也很的好莱坞。约翰。好莱坞。好吧。听众朋友们，我一开始先道个歉。
Listener, for you, you're going to have to listen to us. Just do a bunch of catching up now. It's going to be a lot of memory lane. A lot of memory lane. All right. So you are talking to us from a beautifully appointed room. Children's room. A beautifully wall-papered listener.
听众朋友们，你们接下来得听我们聊天了。现在就是叙叙旧。这会是一次满满的回忆之旅。满满的回忆之旅。好吧。所以你正在一个布置精美的房间里跟我们对话。儿童房。一个墙纸贴得很漂亮的房间，听众朋友们。
I'll have you know. Is that a children's room or is it a guest room? It's a child's room. Which child? I don't know. I was taking a walk and just ducked into the first house I could find. Wow. And they were all set up for the podcast.
我得告诉你们。那是儿童房还是客房？那是儿童房。哪个孩子的？我不知道。我当时在散步，然后随便钻进了找到的第一栋房子里。哇。而且他们把播客的一切都布置好了。
Good for them that they had the microphone and everything. Now, John, how many kids now? Six. Two kids? Seven. Just the two. Oh, sorry. I mean in total, not just with Emily.
真不错，他们连麦克风什么的都准备好了。话说，约翰，现在有几个孩子了？六个。两个孩子？七个。就两个。哦，抱歉。我是说总共，不只是和艾米莉生的。
Oh, sorry. I thought you meant just with Emily. Six. Yeah. It's six. Good for you. Wait, Johnny. So tell us how old are the girls now?
哦，对不起。我以为你是指只和艾米莉生的。六个。对。是六个。那真不错。等等，强尼。快告诉我们女孩们现在多大了？
Eight and six. Eight and six. God. How are you, by the way? I'm great, Sean. How you doing? I'm good. It's good to see you.
八岁和六岁。八岁和六岁。天哪。顺便问一下，你最近怎么样？我很好，肖恩。你怎么样？我很好。很高兴见到你。
It's so nice to see you. Jason, when you hear him talk about his two daughters, eight and six, are you like, you look back fondly on not remembering your daughters when they were that age? Do I have daughters? Yeah. Oh, shit. Yeah. I think I met your daughters when they were around eight and six.
很高兴见到你。杰森，当你听到他谈论自己八岁和六岁的两个女儿时，你会不会觉得，回想起女儿们那个年纪时，你不记得她们的样子而感到有些美妙？我有女儿吗？对。哦，操。对。我想我见过你的女儿们，大约八岁和六岁的时候。
Yeah. Yep. Well, they're now 16 and 11. No, they got it. They were older. They were older. I mean, younger. They were younger.
对。没跑。好吧，她们现在16岁和11岁了。不，她们懂了。她们长大了。她们长大了。我是说，年轻。她们更年轻。
Yeah, they were. Yeah, yeah. For sure. You're in your back east. You live east. No, right now I am down under. I'm talking to you from the future. I'm in Australia because Emily's shooting in Australia.
对，她们是。没错，没错。肯定的。你在东部。你住在东部。不，我现在在南半球。我从未来跟你们对话。我在澳大利亚，因为艾米莉在澳大利亚拍戏。
Oh, sure. Fall guy. Fall guy. Yeah, fall guy. So if you guys want to know how yesterday went, it went great. Really? How were the hot costs yesterday? Did they go over under with that guy Leech?
哦，当然。《特技狂人》。《特技狂人》。对，《特技狂人》。所以如果你们想知道昨天过得怎么样，过得好极了。真的吗？昨天的特技演员怎么样？他们跟那个叫雷奇的家伙合作得怎么样？
Right. Leech. That guy knows how to direct a movie. Man, bullet train. He sure does, right? Dave Leech. I love Dave Leech. I love bullet train.
对。雷奇。那家伙懂怎么导演电影。天哪，《子弹列车》。他确实懂，对吧？大卫·雷奇。我喜欢大卫·雷奇。我喜欢《子弹列车》。
That was real fun. Real good. I'm having fun. Wait, are you there? Are you there involved in the same movie or just support? No, I keep going every day, but they keep saying no, not today. Thanks anyway, though. Yeah.
那真的很有趣。真的很棒。我玩得很开心。等等，你在那儿吗？你在那里参与了同一部电影，还是只是去探班？不，我每天都去，但他们一直说不，今天不行。不过还是谢谢了。对。
Thank you. You just keep getting in background line for wardrobe. Yeah, just like on the waterfront style, just at the gate, you know, just waiting. But did you, you just finished a movie though, right? Did you just? I did. I just wrapped this movie that I wrote and directed called if with Ryan Reynolds. And a unbelievable actress named Kaylee Fleming, who is the really the lead of the movie.
谢谢。你只是去服装部排队领群演服装。对，就像在《码头风云》里那种风格，就在大门那儿，你知道的，就在那儿等着。不过你，不过你刚拍完一部电影，对吧？你刚刚——是的。我刚拍完这部我自编自导的电影，叫《分期梦幻》（IF），由瑞安·雷诺兹主演。还有一个叫卡莉·弗莱明的不起眼的不可思议的女演员，她真的是这部电影的主演。
She's incredible. No more incredible actress than Ryan Reynolds though. He's good times. He was speaking highly of all you guys. I love him. I've listened to every single one of your shows. No, that's not true. I have every single one.
她太不可思议了。不过没有比瑞安·雷诺兹更不可思议的女演员了。他这人挺好的。他对你们所有人评价都很高。我爱死他了。我听了你们每一个节目。不，那不是真的。我每一集都听过。
You know why? Cause it's, it feels like we're all hanging out again. That's what it feels like. Yeah. So I was texting with John and he was, I was texting with John last night. My last night, his two weeks ago, two weeks in the future. I don't know. Fortnite.
你知道为什么吗？因为，这感觉就像我们又聚在一起了。感觉就是这样。所以我和约翰发短信了，我昨晚和约翰发短信。我昨晚，他那是两周前，未来两周的事。我不知道。两周后。
I forget how it works, but he, yeah, it was at least a fortnight in the future. And he says to me, mate, he says, I'm really excited to do the pot. Yeah. Cause he really gets right in there. He says that I really, I'm looking forward to it because it's going to feel like hanging out again. And I was like, oh yeah, it's been a fucking minute since we. Well, you're on.
我忘了它是怎么运作的，但总之，是的，至少是未来的两个星期后。他对我说，老兄，他说，我真的很高兴能上这个播客。是的，因为他真的很投入。他说我真的，我很期待，因为这会感觉像是又聚在一起了。当时我就想，哦，是的，我们他妈的好久没——好吧，你一直在忙。
I've been busy crushing it as a director. I know. Congratulations on that, Joni. Thank you so much guys. I mean, my God. You and I, you and I have had some conversations since I've been absolutely stunned by all your stuff. Oh, Jay.
你作为导演一直忙着大获成功呢。我知道。祝贺你取得的成就，强尼。非常感谢你们，伙计们。我是说，天哪。自从我看到你的所有作品以来，我和你，我和你进行过几次交谈，我都惊呆了。哦，杰。
Thank you. So great. Tell us, tell us, thank you. Tell, tell us what, what is, what is if, is if in the same genre as, as Quiet Place? It's not. I, I took a whole left turn there and. Is it comedic? It's not.
谢谢。太棒了。告诉我们，告诉我们，谢谢。告诉我们，告诉我们，这个《分期梦幻》，《分期梦幻》和《寂静之地》是同一个类型的吗？不是的。我，我来了一个一百八十度大转弯，然后——是喜剧吗？不是。
It's a, I mean, it is, it is comedic. It's basically a, it's my movie that I wrote for my kids. So it's about imaginary friends and the power of these adorable things. Aren't just adorable. They're a time capsules for all our hopes, dreams and ambitions. So what if we could tap back into that? What if we can tap back into it? I smell tears.
这是一部，我的意思是，它是喜剧。基本上它是我为我的孩子们写的一部电影。所以它是关于想象中的朋友以及这些可爱的小东西的力量。不只是可爱。它们是我们所有的希望、梦想和雄心的时光胶囊。所以如果我们能重新连结那个状态呢？如果我们能重新连结那个状态呢？我闻到了眼泪的味道。
There's a probably a nice moment in there. Ryan can get you to cry. So can you. Oh boy. Ryan can do it real well. Well. One of the things that I love about craze and I always have. Take it down.
那里面可能有一个不错的时刻。瑞安能让你哭出来。你也能。哦，天哪。瑞安真的很擅长这个。好吧。我喜欢卡拉的其中一点，我一直都这样。冷静点。
Make it. Is that he's an emotional guy wears his heart on his sleeve. There, I don't know if I know anybody. Cry everything. More emotional and who, who's so open about it. And it's a real superpower. Yeah. He's got his teeth.
把它变成——就是他是一个感性的人，喜怒形于色。在那里，我不知道我是否认识任何人。哭得稀里哗啦。更加感性，而且对此如此坦诚。这真的是一种超能力。是的。他露出了牙齿。
He's got his nose. And he will. And he has like, I can't tell you how many times over the years craze is like, grab my arm or my shoulder and be like, can you believe this dinner we have or whatever it is. And then he'll be, and he'll be well. It makes me sound like a psychopath. No. It's that state.
他露出了鼻子。而且他会。他就像——我无法告诉你，这些年来，卡拉有多少次抓住我的胳膊或肩膀说：“你能相信我们有这样的晚宴或者诸如此类的事吗？”然后他就会，他就会情绪激动。这让我听起来像个精神病。不。就是那种状态。
I love it because it's so, it's because you get so passionate about stuff and you really and it goes to everything you're passionate about the people you love. You're passionate about your wife, your kids, your work, all of it. You don't do anything. There are zero half measure. I don't think I've ever seen you do anything in a half measure, including playing a video game. Oh my God.
我喜欢它，因为它太——因为你对事物充满热情，你真的，它延伸到你热衷的一切：你爱的人，你的妻子，你的孩子，你的工作，所有这一切。你做事从不含糊。我觉得我从未见你做过任何事情是半途而废的，包括玩电子游戏。天哪。
You remember that? Oh, you guys not play call of duty anymore with your headsets and. We, before we got into call of duty, we headed over to Twitter or HMV or something and bought three systems, three cheap TVs and set them up in the same room like minority report. Me and craze and Thoreau. And we did like a hotel at the hotel. We did a three day weekend in LA playing these video games. Bender.
你还记得那个吗？哦，你们不玩《使命召唤》了，戴着耳机和——我们在玩《使命召唤》之前，我们去了推特大厦或HMV还是什么地方，买了三个系统，三台便宜的电视，把它们设置在同一个房间里，就像《少数派报告》里那样。我和卡拉还有梭罗。我们在洛杉矶的一个酒店里度过了一个为期三天的周末，一直在玩这些电子游戏。纵情狂欢。
Usually there's crystal meth involved in something like that. You remember, it was so weird that at one point, you remember Janine was staying there offload and she came over and she was making, she was making bead, like she was making bracelets and she was there and we weren't even talking. She's like, eventually she's like, well, I'm going to leave. You guys aren't even talking because we were all like, go get the deal. Yeah. We were in a hotel.
通常这种事情都会扯上冰毒什么的。你还记得吗，太诡异了，有一次，你还记得珍妮当时住在附近，她过来做，她一直在做珠子，就像她在做手链一样，她在那儿，我们甚至都没说话。她最后说：“好吧，我要走了。你们甚至都不说话，”因为我们都在那儿——去拿下那笔交易。我们在一家酒店里。
Yeah. We went down to dinner will and she told us she was there and we said we had no recollection. She was there. We said that we didn't know she was in and then she told us she was making bracelets with beads. But Sean, go ahead, Sean. No, no. You go. I was going to talk about what's going on down there in Australia.
是的。威尔，我们下楼去吃晚饭，她告诉我们她在那里，我们说我们一点都不记得她在那里了。我们说我们不知道她在里面，然后她告诉我们她一直在用珠子做手链。不过肖恩，说吧，肖恩。不，不。你来。我本来想说在澳大利亚那边发生的事情。
Tell me, what's your average day now that down there as, as sort of playing dad, you're bringing the girls to the set to coordinate with lunchtime or. Well, the girls are in school here. We always throw the girls in school. I'm here for another eight weeks and then I'm editing a little bit, but then I go back to New York to edit, but the girls will stay here, I think for 10 weeks and then Emily's here for 12 more weeks. Wow.
告诉我，你现在在那边作为，某种程度上扮演老爸的日常是怎样的，你把女儿们带到片场来配合午餐时间还是——嗯，女儿们在这里上学。我们总是把女儿们送去学校。我要在这里再呆八周，然后我要剪辑一会儿，但接着我要回纽约去剪辑，不过女儿们会留在这里，我想呆10周，然后艾米莉要在这里再呆12周。哇。
Wow. That's a long time. Wow. I've never been here, by the way. Will, you've been here. Drew Form just told me that you guys flew together. Yeah. I've been there twice with Drew.
哇。那可真长。哇。我从来没去过那儿，顺便说一句。威尔，你去过那儿。德鲁·福姆刚刚告诉我你们是一起飞过去的。是的。我和德鲁去过两次。
And not only that, I don't look around, but I actually, I'm like Mr. Australia. I just did it with Rose Burn. I just did a big campaign for tourism Australia. Some kind of like represent. What? Yes. Yes. I've seen it now.
不仅如此，我不四处张望，但实际上，我简直就像是澳大利亚先生。我刚刚和罗斯·伯恩一起。我刚刚为澳大利亚旅游局拍了一个大型宣传活动。某种代言。什么？是的。是的。我现在看到了。
Is it out yet? Yeah. Boy. That's incredible. How many pages down on the list do you think they were? I mean, why would they go? Oh my God. What about Will Arnett just screams, oh, fuck, we got to get Will Arnett to sell Australia
已经播出了吗？是的。天哪。太不可思议了。你觉得他们在名单上排在第几页？我是说，他们为什么会去找？哦，天哪。威尔·阿奈特有什么特点能让人觉得，“哦，操，我们得让威尔·阿奈特来把澳大利亚”
to the world. When I think of the outback. You know it's funny about that. When I get Rose Burn, at least, is Australian. Go ahead, Kras. Yeah. You know what's funny about that? Well, do you remember when we were at Margarita Mix, I've only had one voice campaign in
推销给全世界。当我想起内陆地区时。关于那个，你知道最搞笑的是什么吗？当我找到罗斯·伯恩时，至少她是个澳大利亚人。说吧，卡拉。是的。关于那个，你知道最搞笑的是什么吗？好吧，你还记得我们在玛格丽塔混音录音室的时候吗？我一生中只接过一个配音广告，
my life because they heard what I had and they said thanks anyway. It's the voiceover studio here in town. It was for insurance. I thank you. Yeah. Click or call. Anyway, but I was in the booth. I was in the booth doing the script and in walks Will and he's like, Kras, what's going
因为他们听了我录的声音然后说“谢谢，还是算了”。这是镇上的一家配音工作室。那是为了保险。谢谢你。对。点击或致电。总之，我在录音棚里，在录音棚里念台词，这时威尔走了进来，他说：“卡拉，怎么了？”他们就说：“威尔，芝加哥的那帮人说，威尔，是你吗？”他凑到麦克风前说：“嘿，是谁呀？”他们就说：“是安迪和戴夫。”然后他说：“安迪，戴夫，怎么了？”你就能听到这群家伙在说：“你觉得他可能会拒绝吗？嘿，老兄，快离开录音棚。这是我目前仅有的工作了。”
on? And they were like, Will, the guys in Chicago were like, Will, is that you? He gets on the mic and he's like, Hey, who is it? And they were like, it's Andy and Dave. And he was like, Andy, Dave, what's going on? And you could hear these dudes going, you think he might take a pass? Hey, man, get out of the booth. This is all I've got right now.
威尔，现在就给我们来一个“点击或致电”。我太喜欢“点击或致电”保险了。哦，不。哦，天哪。他们要把它复活了。他们承担不起的。等一下。是的。
Will, give us a click or call right now. I'm such a click or call insurance. Oh, no. Oh, God. They're going to revive it. They can't afford it. Hang on a second. Yeah.
哦，操。搬家卡车的哔哔声会毁了音频吗？这家伙。嘿，你介意让我试一次吗？好吧。让我们听听，强尼。好的。台词是什么？
Oh, shit. Is this going to wreck the audio, the beeping of the bringstruck? This guy. Hey, do you mind if I give it a go once? Yeah. Let's hear it, Shani. Okay. What's the line?
点击或致电。点击或致电。好的，准备好了吗？保险。对。对。这只是保险。哦，保险。
Click or call. Click or call. Okay, ready? Insurance. Yeah. Yeah. It's just insurance. Oh, insurance.
这只是保险。但这太疯狂了，因为我记得，威尔，你对着麦克风说：“你们需要更有卡车司机味儿吗？”当时我就想：“拜托，老兄。”更有卡车司机味儿。拜托。记得吗？卡拉是我最喜欢的。
It's just insurance. But it's crazy because I remember, Will, you said into the microphone, do you guys need it truckier? And I was like, come on, man. Truckier. Come on. Remember? Cras is one of my favorite.
我们有太多的回忆了。我是说，真他妈的，天哪。这是我们这些年来第一次度过，我当时在想有一次，我都不知道这是多久以前的事了，但我们在，你还记得这个吗？我们在灰色之狗咖啡馆，在纽约卡迈因街的那家。哦，是的。我们在喝咖啡。
We have so many memories. I mean, we fuck, man. Holy shit. This is the first time that we spent over the years and I was thinking about one time, I don't even know how long ago this was, but we were down at, do you remember this? We're at the gray dog, the one on Carmine Street in New York. Oh, yeah. We're having coffee.
那就像一个，我不知道。那就像是一个周三早晨什么的。你知道我要说什么。我们坐在那儿，人们从旁边走过，我们就开始说：“看那个家伙。”我们对每个人评头论足。我们说：“看那个该死的失败者。嘿，真他妈不错的牛仔裤。”就只是为了互相逗乐。
It was like a, I don't know. It was like a Wednesday morning or something. You know where I'm going with this. And we're sitting there and people were walking by and we're like, look at this guy. We had the comments for everybody. We're like, look at this freaking loser. Hey, nice fucking jeans. Just to each other, make each other laugh.
然后我们安静了一会儿，然后我们突然说：“天哪，巴特曼一定会喜欢这个。”到处乱扔刻薄的垃圾。顺便说一句，我认为离开洛杉矶最大的遗憾，绝对是离开你们。艾米莉说过，她最怀念的事就是看到我们三个挤在角落里，一直在抖包袱，完全与其他人隔绝，只为了我们三个提供笑料和娱乐。既可悲又令人讨厌。
And then we're kind of quiet for a second and we just go, God, Bateman would love this. Just tossing shit bombs. By the way, I think the biggest regret of leaving, definitely the biggest regret of leaving LA was leaving you guys. And Emily said that the thing she'll miss most is seeing the three of us in a corner, just doing bits, just completely isolated from the rest of the group, just doing, serving up bits and entertaining to only us three. Just pathetic and obnoxious.
哦，天哪。我们马上回来。SmartLess智能无知播客由威廉斯堡旅游局赞助播出。在威廉斯堡，美好的事物永远不会嫌多。无论你是美食爱好者、高尔夫球手、历史迷、购物狂、户外运动爱好者、惊险刺激追求者，你都能在这里找到你想要的东西——从过山车到水上乐园，从徒步旅行到皮划艇。威廉斯堡是各种冒险活动的绝佳去处。
Oh God. We'll be right back. SmartLess is brought to you in part by Visit Williamsburg. In Williamsburg, there's never too much of a good thing. Whether you're a foodie, a golfer, a history buff, a shopaholic, an outdoor enthusiast, a thrill seeker, you're going to find what you came for from roller coasters to water parks, hiking and kayaking. Williamsburg is great for adventures of all kinds.
这里拥有十多个四星级高尔夫球场，已成为东部首屈一指的高尔夫胜地之一。南方的舒适只是其新兴餐饮业的一小部分，从现代菜肴到经典美食，从精致餐饮到外带快餐，从当地精酿啤酒厂到迷人的酒庄，威廉斯堡能满足各种胃口。探索美国第一个英国定居点詹姆斯敦的遗址，或是芝加哥，或者在历史悠久的威廉斯堡和约克镇古色古香的街道上购物。
And with over a dozen four-star golf courses, it's become one of the East's premier golf destinations. Southern Comfort is just a taste of what their emerging food and beverage scene has to offer, from contemporary cuisine to the classics, fine dining to food on the go, and local craft breweries to stunning wineries. Williamsburg will satiate any appetite. Explore the grounds of America's first English settlement in Jamestown, or Chicago, or shop along the quaint streets of historic Williamsburg and Yorktown.
深入研究我们国家最早定居者的法医历史，或者体验其中一员的日常生活。这不仅是一个了解我们共同历史的地方，更是一个亲身体验它的地方。威廉斯堡是一个你可以一次又一次重访，并获得完全不同体验的目的地。来到威廉斯堡，以你的节奏生活。现在就访问visitwilliamsburg.com开始规划你的旅行吧。SmartList由NerdWallet赞助播出。SmartList的听众们，你们喜欢听我们节目，这真是太贴心了，尽管
Dig into the forensics of our country's earliest settlers, or experience a day in the life of one. This isn't just a place to learn about our shared history, it's a place to live it. Williamsburg is the type of destination that you can come back to again and again and have a completely different experience. Come to Williamsburg to live life at your pace. Start planning your trip today at visitwilliamsburg.com. SmartList is brought to you in part by NerdWallet. SmartList listeners, you like to listen to us and that's very sweet of you, even though
你们明白我们并不聪明、有才华，而且我们当中有一个人超级帅。那可能现在正在跟你说话，当然，但聪明绝对不是我们的强项。这就是我们的赞助商NerdWallet发挥作用的地方，你可以在这里并排比较顶级金融产品，做出明智的financial决定。NerdWallet拥有一个由书呆子组成的团队，可以帮助你为你的下一张信用卡、高收益储蓄账户等做出明智的决定。这些人可不仅仅是自称聪明，他们是那种真正聪明的人。他们拥有CFP证书（无论那代表什么）、MBA学位（无论那代表什么）、多年的经验，
you understand we are not smart, talented, and one of us is super handsome. That's probably talking to you right now, sure, but smart is not one of our strong suits. That's where our sponsor comes in, NerdWallet, where you can compare top financial products side by side and make smart financial decisions. NerdWallet has a whole team of nerds who help you make smart decisions on your next credit card, high yield savings account, and more. And these aren't people who just say they're smart, they're like actual smart. They've got CFPs, whatever that means, MBAs, whatever that means, years of experience,
他们正利用自己的专业知识为你提供顶级金融产品的并排比较和客观评级。你最近在汽油和杂货上花更多钱了吗？你当然花了。这个世界就是这样。这个世界太糟糕了。把负面转化为正面，寻找一张能为你花费最多的地方提供现金返还的卡。所以对我来说，我会从我喜欢的东西上获得现金返还，比如外出就餐、网上购物。
and they're using their expertise to offer side by side comparisons and objective ratings on top financial products for you. Are you spending more on gas and groceries lately? Of course you are. The world is. The world is terrible. Turn that negative into a positive and find a cashback card that rewards you for what you spend the most on. So for me, I would get cashback on things that I love, like dining out, online shopping.
我很喜欢外出就餐，因为你对家里有的东西，或者送到你家的东西，或者其他什么东西都感到厌倦了，但这些都很棒。但有时，你知道的，你喜欢出去走走，所以我喜欢外出就餐，就像，我不知道，一周一次，每两周一次，感觉挺不错的。所以听众朋友们，是时候停止耍小聪明，开始和NerdWallet的书呆子们一起变得聪明起来了。在nerdwallet.com比较并寻找顶级现金返还信用卡、储蓄账户等。NerdWallet，你所有财务决策的最明智选择。SmartLess由BetterHelp赞助播出。
I like dining out a lot because you get sick of the stuff that's at your house or that's sent to your house or whatever, but it's all great. But sometimes, you know, you like to go out and so I like to dine out like, I don't know, once a week, once every other week, it's kind of nice. So listeners, it's time to stop being smartless and time to get smart with the Nerds at NerdWallet. Compare and find top cashback credit cards, savings account, and more at nerdwallet.com. NerdWallet, the smartest decision for all your financial decisions. SmartLess is sponsored by BetterHelp.
有太多的事情，人们称之为生活小窍门，但通常它们只是讲得通的事情。这些事情，对我来说，那些讲得通且能让我对自己感觉良好的事情其实非常简单。因为我希望在任何时候都能展现最好的自己，因为当我展现最好的自己并且感觉，你知道的，感觉状态最佳时，我就会感觉更好，而我所做的事情之一就是自我照顾。自我照顾对我来说是最重要的事，那可能是锻炼。那可能是与非常积极的人交谈，与对生活有伟大视角的人交谈。此外，其中一件事就是与治疗师交谈。多年来，我发现这真的非常非常有帮助，因为它让我能够展现最好的自己。
There are so many things, people call them life hacks, but often they're just things that make sense. Things that, for me, the things that make sense that I do to help me feel good about myself are really simple. Because I want to be my best self at all times because when I'm being my best self and feeling, you know, my best self, then I feel better and one of the things I do is self care. Self care is the most important thing to me and that might be exercising. That might be talking to people who are really positive, people who have a great perspective on life. Also, one of those things is talking to a therapist. I've found it over the years to be really, really helpful because it allows me to be my best self.
当你处于最佳状态时，你可以做伟大的事情，但有时生活会让你陷入泥潭，你会感到不知所措，或者觉得自己没有按照你想要的方式表现出来。所以再次强调，我觉得与治疗师合作可以帮助你更接近最佳版本的自己，因为当你感到赋能时，你就会，你会更有准备去应对生活抛给你的一切。在我的人生中，有很多次事情并没有按我想要的方向发展，或者我只是觉得我被卡住了，每次去看治疗师。每次我做完之后，我都觉得感觉好多了，而且我很高兴我这么做了。有时候迈出第一步去寻求帮助并不容易，
And when you're at your best, you can do great things, but sometimes life gets you bogged down and you can feel overwhelmed or like you're not showing up in the way that you want to. So again, I feel like working with a therapist can help you get closer to the best version of you because when you feel empowered, you're just, you're more prepared to take on everything life throws at you. And I've had so many moments in my life where things weren't going the way I wanted them to, or I just didn't feel like I was kind of jammed up going to a therapist every single time. Every time I did it, I felt better after I'd done it and I was happy I did. And sometimes it's not easy to take that first step and ask for help
因为你会有各种各样的疑虑，比如我需要这么做吗？我真的想深入了解吗？而每一次，在另一面我都会感觉更好。所以如果你正在考虑尝试心理治疗，BetterHelp是一个绝佳的选择。它方便、灵活、实惠，而且完全在线。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与有执照的治疗师匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。如果你想过上更有力量的生活，心理治疗能帮你实现。
because you're going to have all those sort of doubts about, do I need to do this and do I really want to get into it? And every time I feel better on the flip side. So if you're thinking of giving therapy a try, better help is a great option. It's convenient, flexible, affordable, and it's entirely online. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched up with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. If you want to live a more empowered life, therapy can get you there.
今天就访问betterhelp.com斜杠smartless，首月即可享受10%的折扣。网址是betterhelp点H-E-L-P点com斜杠smartless。现在回到节目中。强尼，我其实有个真正的问题要问你。好的。也就是……我敢说你没有。
Visit betterhelp.com slash smartless today to get 10% off your first month. That's better help. H-E-L-P.com slash smartless. And now back to the show. Johnny, I actually have a real question for you. Okay. Which is... I'll bet you don't.
首先，是……剧院故事。相信我，如果有的话，我洗耳恭听。那是最好的故事。嘿，约翰，最疯狂的是什么？我甚至说不出口。说吧。顺便说一句，你知道吗？
First of all, is... Theater stories. Believe me, if any, I'm all ears. They're the best stories. Hey, John, what's the craziest? I can't even get it out. Go ahead. By the way, you know what?
你们取笑我向别人要剧院故事，而它们最后总是滑稽之作。它们总是这样。是真的。而且我发现听节目的听友们也非常喜欢它们。事实上，约翰是个名副其实的剧院圈内人。所以如果你有什么糟糕透顶、可怕的故事。好吧，太棒了。
You guys make fun of me asking people for theater stories, and they always end up being hilarious. They always have. It's true. And I find for people who listen to the show that they fucking love them too. And actually, John is a legitimate theater guy. So if you have any awful, horrible stories. Okay, great.
但我真的有个真正的问题。我把它写在这里了。肖恩，我最后会问他的。是的。只演过一出戏。那完全是个噩梦。不，说真的？哦，你不是在布朗大学学过剧本创作吗？
But I really have a real question. I've got it written down right here. Sean, I'll get to him at the end. Yeah. Only did one play. It was all at Nightmare. No, for real? Oh, didn't you study playwriting at Brown?
剧本创作，对，不是戏剧表演。我在学校演过几部戏，但没有。我基本上是在毕业后才去了一所戏剧学校。我是布朗大学的中途插班生，所以每个人都在五月份毕业。我还有一个学期。那是为了什么，只为了在家生孩子？你可以别提在家生孩子了。我肯定在想别的。
Playwriting, yeah, not play performing. I did a couple plays at school, but no. I basically went to a theater school after I graduated. I was a mid-year at Brown, so everybody graduated in May. I still had a semester. And that's what, just for home births? You can stop with home births. I'm thinking of something else for sure.
我绝对在想别的。我知道那里面有东西。有什么有趣的戏剧写作故事吗？我很想听一个搞笑的戏剧写作故事。不，那只是，那纯粹是折磨。好吧，因为你一个人关在房间里写作。这有什么好笑的？他这不就来了。
I'm definitely thinking of something else. I knew there was something there. Are there any funny theater writing stories? I'd love to hear a theater writing story funny thing. No, that's just, that was all just torturous. Well, because you're alone in a room writing. What's funny about that? There he is.
他懂的。好吧，等等，但我有个问题吗？所以《寂静之地》。那是你的第一部导演作品吗，还是不是？不是。不是。不，威尔出演了我的导演处女作。没错。
He knows it. Okay, so wait, but do I have a question? So a quiet place. Was that your first directing gig or no? No. It wasn't. No, Will was in my directorial debut. That's right.
那是叫什么？威尔出演了。那是对大卫·福斯特·华莱士的一本名为《与丑陋男人的短暂访谈》的书的改编。威尔出演了。他可能在里面主演吧？其中一个丑陋的男人。可能是领衔主演，名字排在片名上面。
Which was what? Will was in it. It was an adaptation of a David Foster Wallace book called Brief Interviews with Hideous Men. And Will was in it. He was probably starring in it, right? One of the Hideous Men. Probably headlining the name above title.
不，他太好了，主动加入了。他来客串了这个小角色。太棒了。太棒了。所以我的严肃问题很蠢，那就是是什么让你从一个演员转变为想要成为一名导演？有没有某个人、某个时刻或者某些事，
And, no, he was so nice to jump in. He came in and did this small part. It was amazing. It was amazing. So my serious question is dumb, which is what made you go from being an actor to wanting to be a director? Was there a person, a moment or something
当时你正身处《办公室》的片场，然后想，我有点想做这个。比起演戏，我更对它是如何制作出来的感兴趣。我想我脑海深处一直有这种想法，但我从没想过自己有信心去导演。当时我正坐在一家墨西哥卷饼店里。
where you were on the set of the office and go, I kind of want to do this. I'd rather, I'm more interested in how it's made than being in it. I think there was something happening in the back of my head, but I never thought I'd have the confidence to direct. And I was actually sitting at a burrito place.
在洛杉矶叫什么来着？Chipotle。Sharkies。哦，对。我和雷恩·威尔逊先生坐在一起，他看到我有点困惑，就问怎么了。
What's it called in LA? Chipotle. Sharkies. Sharkies. Oh, yeah. I was sitting with Mr. Rainn Wilson and he saw that I was a bit perplexed and he said, what's going on?
我说：“我正在找人来导演我写的一部电影，叫《与丑陋男人的短暂访谈》。”他说：“你为什么不自己拍呢？”我的大脑瞬间当机了，我说：“你在说什么？”然后他说：“你直接拍不就行了。”于是我就拍了。他鼓励我去导演它。然后在那个期间，剧组的人听说
I said, I'm trying to get somebody to direct this movie I wrote called Brief Interviews with Hideous Men. He goes, why don't you do it? And my brain shut off and I went, what are you talking about? And he was like, you should just do it. And so I did. And he encouraged me to direct it. And then in between then, the people at the office heard
我要导演一部电影。所以他们说：“你为什么不导演几集来练练手呢？”《办公室》就是我的整个电影学校，是我能梦想的一切。我在那部剧里得到了最纯粹的形式，从我们拥有的不可思议的编剧团队到这些不可思议的剪辑师。
that I was going to direct a film. So they said, why don't you direct a couple episodes to get your feet wet. And the office was my entire film school, everything I could ever dream of. I got in the purest form on that show from, I mean, the unbelievable writer's room that we had to these unbelievable editors.
而且你甚至在成为演员之前就是个作家，甚至在成为导演之前。你首先是个作家吗？算是吧。我大学主修英语。在大四的时候，我选修了一门课程，我因此进入了荣誉剧作家项目。什么大学？
And you were a writer before even an actor, before even a director. Were you a writer first? Sort of. I was an English major in college. And in my senior year, I took a course, which I got into the honors playwright program. What college?
罗德岛州普罗виден斯（Providence）的布朗大学。好吧，太棒了。明白了。我听说过。好吧，肖恩。我讲完了。如果你想的话我们可以结束。这旁边就像在搞什么三审一样
Brown University in Providence, Rhode Island. Okay, great. Got it. I've heard of it. Okay, Sean. I'm done. We can wrap it up if you want. There's a fucking third degree over here
搞得他像个罪犯似得。我不知道发生了什么。为什么卡拉现在遭受迫害？顺便说一句，再次被叫卡拉感觉太棒了。没有人叫我卡拉。难道没有其他人叫你卡拉吗？没有。没有人。
like he's a criminal. I don't know what's going on. Why is Crasse being persecuted right now? By the way, it just feels so good to be called Crasse again. Nobody has called me Crasse. Does nobody else call you Crasse? No. Nobody.
我这些年来的所有手机里，我的备注全都是卡拉。所以，就像我每次听到你的名字出现时，我就想，威尔，你知道你在我的手机里是怎么显示的吗。你知道你是怎么出场的。不，保持干净。
All my phones throughout the years, it's all Crasse on my thing. And so like I'm just like, so when your name anytime comes up, I was like, Well, you know how you come up on my phone. You know how you come out. No, keep it clean.
保持干净。凯丽·罗塞尔的。什么？在《碟中谍3》里爆头的那张。没错。顺便说一句。我完全知道你在说什么。约翰，告诉他们为什么。
Keep it clean. Carrie Russell's. What? The pop die in Mission Impossible 3. That's right. By the way. I know exactly what you're talking about. John, tell them why.
告诉他们为什么。告诉他们为什么。我最喜欢的电影之一。威尔和我曾经对《碟中谍》痴迷不已。当然。《谍影重重》之类的一切。我们真的会坐在第一排。我是说，在其他任何人类进入影院之前，
Tell them why. Tell them why. One of my favorite movies. Will and I were obsessed with Mission Impossible. Of course. Born all that stuff. We would literally go sit front row. I mean, before any other humans were in the theater,
我们就已经坐在那里了，我们为所有的电影做好了准备。我们看了。当我们看到《碟中谍3》里凯丽·罗塞尔的脑袋里炸弹爆炸，她的眼睛扭曲时，我们俩互相撞了一下，笑得前俯后仰。我是说，简直在互相摇晃。我把它弄成了。
we were there and we were prepared for all the movies. And we saw them. And when we saw Mission Impossible 3 and Carrie Russell has a bomb go off in her head and her eye twisted, we hit each other and laughed so hard. I mean, just shaking each other. And I made it.
我把它设置成了来电头像，所以当威尔打电话来时，就是这个。就是这个。他也会这样对我的。有时他会——我们在外面。有些人正在说话。他会转向我然后说——
I made it the picture so that when Will calls, it's this. It's just this. He'll do it to me. Sometimes he'll just like, we'll be out. Some people talking. He'll turn to me and just go,
我把它设成了照片，所以当威尔打电话来时，就是这个。就只是这个。他也会这样对我。有时他就会，比如说，我们一起出去。有些人正在说话。他会转过身来对我说：
like, do the, I think. And the other thing we do to each other. I think I mentioned this to JJ when he was on the show. Abrams, the little brown dot that they never explained that they just put on the arm. And when they, like in the movie, at some point the guy just walks up and just goes, puts this brown dot on the person, just slumps.
比如，去做那个，我想。还有一件事是我们对彼此做过的。我想我上次JJ来节目的时候跟他说过。J·J·艾布拉姆斯，那个他们从没解释过、只是贴在手臂上的小棕点。当他们在电影里，某个时刻那家伙突然走过去，把这个棕点贴在那人身上，然后人就瘫倒了。
I'm like, what is the brown dot? It's the deadly freckle. It's a poison dart. And also Billy Crudup's character mouths to Tom. He goes, yeah. And they have a conversation just mouthing. Right. But Will, do you remember we were at a party
我就想，这个棕点到底是什么？这是致命的雀斑。这是一支毒镖。还有比利·克鲁德普的角色对汤姆无声地动了动嘴唇。他说，对。他们就靠对口型在对话。没错。但是，维尔，你还记得我们在一个派对上吗？
and JJ had just directed the office. And he goes, I can't believe I remember this. And I'm so embarrassed to say this story. JJ goes, hey man, you want to meet Tom Cruise. What? And I was like 24, 25 or something. And he's like, come on over. And I go up and Tom's coming down the stairs
当时J·J刚导演完《办公室》。他说，我不敢相信我居然还记得这个。而且我说出这个故事觉得好尴尬。J·J说，嘿，老兄，你想见汤姆·克鲁斯吗？什么？我当时大概24、25岁左右。他说，过来吧。然后我走过去，汤姆正走下楼梯，
with like four bodyguards. And I don't know how, Will's watching me. And I don't know how I had the guts to do this. I went up and pretended to put a brown dot on his wrist. A poison dart on his wrist. And the four bodyguards moved on me and were going to kill me before I started mouthing to Tom.
带着大概四个保镖。我不知道怎么回事，维尔正看着我。我也不知道我当时哪来的胆子做这件事。我走过去假装在他的手腕上贴了一个棕点。在他手腕上扎了一支毒镖。那四个保镖立刻朝我扑过来，打算在我开始对汤姆动嘴型之前把我干掉。
And he went, and he started laughing. And he gave me like a hug and was like, this guy's okay. But for a second they thought I was going to murder them. That's awesome. Because he geeked out. We used to go down to my old apartment on the west side in New York. And we used to go watch movies downtown.
然后他笑了，他给了我一个拥抱，说，这家伙没事。但有那么一秒钟，他们以为我要谋杀他们。太棒了。因为他兴奋得不行。我们以前常去我在纽约西区的老公寓。我们经常去市中心看电影。
And then we'd see like, we saw all those movies down in those theaters. And we saw The Mission Impossible and all the born movies. And then we, do you remember we'd like run up and we'd be all gacked out on like M&Ms and popcorn or whatever. And we'd run up the west side highway.
然后我们会去看，我们在那些影院里看了所有那些电影。我们看了《碟中谍》和所有的《谍影重重》系列。然后我们，你还记得我们会像那样冲出去，嗑M&M豆和爆米花之类的东西嗨到不行。然后我们冲上西区公路。
Just fucking like kids who were so stoked. Running as if we're like this. Like we'd run like Tom. By the way, I'm in my like mid to late 30s. Oh my God. Mid to late 20s. We used to yell, take the shot with holding our ears. I love that.
就像那些兴奋到不行的傻小子一样。奔跑着，就好像我们在。就像我们像汤姆那样跑。顺便说一句，我当时大概30岁出头到快35岁。天哪。20岁出头到快30岁。我们过去常常一边捂着耳朵一边大喊，“开枪吧”。我太喜欢那个了。
To people on the street. And then we found out Frank Marshall, our buddy was one of the producers. And we made him tell us stories. We apprehended him. And then he ended up sending us wrap gifts from the latest born movie. He sent one.
对着街上的人喊。然后我们发现弗兰克·马歇尔，我们的好朋友，是制片人之一。我们逼他给我们讲故事。我们把他“扣押”了。最后他居然给我们寄了最新一部《谍影重重》的杀青纪念礼物。他寄了一份。
He sent a metal case with like T-shirts and stuff to my house. And Will was so funny because I went, look, look, what do you got? And he goes, but I didn't get one. And I was like, no, I know. And he goes, so what do we do? We had to split up. We had to split up stuff.
他给我家里寄了一个金属箱，里面有T恤之类的东西。维尔太搞笑了，因为我说，看，看，你得到了什么？他说，但我没收到。我说，不，我知道。然后他说，那我们怎么办？我们不得不分。我们不得不把东西分着。
Did you get invited to Conan's Christmas party, John? Ask him, did you get invited to Conan's Christmas party? I bet you a million bucks he did. No? No. How about Emily? Conan O'Brien? Yeah.
约翰，你收到柯南的圣诞派对邀请了吗？问问他，你收到柯南的圣诞派对邀请了吗？我跟你打赌一百万他收到了。没有？没有。艾米莉呢？柯南·奥布莱恩？对。
That's right. Yeah. No, I didn't. And now I'm really sad. I'm really sad about that. When we were in New York and, and, and by the way, Krazy used to work at Conan. When he was living in L.A.
没错。对。不，我没有。现在我真的很难过。我为这事真的很难过。当我们在纽约的时候，而且，而且，顺便说一句，克雷兹以前在柯南那里工作过。当他住在洛杉矶时。
He was an intern there for real. It was his script intern. Yeah. So my job, all the other interns, I got the writing script intern and the greatest part of the job. I couldn't believe it was everybody gave him hair and makeup and all the producers are telling him all these notes of the guests and stuff.
他真的是那里的实习生。他是剧本实习生。对。所以我的工作，所有其他实习生里，我拿到了剧本写作实习生的岗位，这是这份工作最棒的部分。我简直不敢相信，每个人都给他做发型和化妆，所有的制片人都把关于嘉宾的各种注意事项告诉他。
And then they all would clear out for 30 seconds, as Max Weinberg would hit the drums, and I would have 30 seconds alone with Conan where he rehearsed the monologue just to me. Oh, wow. And I would cry laughing every single day. And at the end of the summer, well, what was my favorite joke?
然后他们都会清场30秒，当马克斯·温伯格敲响鼓点时，我会有30秒独自和柯南在一起的时光，他专门只为我一个人排练独白。哦，天哪。我每天都会感动得哭出来。在那个夏天结束时，嗯，我最喜欢哪个笑话？
He's like, yeah, you think these jokes are funny? And I said, yeah. And he goes, really? I thought Kids Your Age just went home, smoked weed and listened to Pearl Jam. That's pretty big. And I was like, well, you're not far off. But then at the end, he brought me into his office.
他说，没错，你觉得这些笑话很好笑？我说，对。他说，真的吗？我以为你们这个年纪的小孩只会回家、抽大麻、听珍珠果酱乐队。这挺牛的。我说，嗯，你猜得八九不离十。但后来在最后，他把我叫进他的办公室。
The last day we were all leaving. He brought me into his office, gave me a Sam Adams, said, I know you're from Boston, here's the Sam Adams. I just wanted to say thank you for laughing every night. You have no idea what it means to have laughter be the last thing you see before you go on stage. And I cried. Oh, he's the greatest.
我们都要离开的那天最后一天。他把我叫进他的办公室，给了我一杯山姆亚当斯啤酒，说，我知道你是波士顿来的，来杯山姆亚当斯。我只是想谢谢你每天晚上都笑。你根本不知道笑声成为我上台前看到的最后一幕意味着什么。我哭了。哦，他太棒了。
I mean, you know what, I burst into tears. Of course you didn't. Conan is the greatest. I'm bursting into tears hearing this. Wait, that's how old I am. And by the way, later, he was my first talk show. So the first talk show I ever did was Conan. So when I went back to do Conan, it was, again, I cried.
我是说，你知道吗，我当场泪崩。你才没有呢。柯南最棒了。我听到这都快泪崩了。等等，我当时就这年纪。而且顺便说一句，后来，他是我的第一个脱口秀节目。所以我参加的第一个脱口秀就是柯南。所以当我回去上柯南的节目时，我又哭了。
But I was walking through the hallways and all these people I used to work for were like, hey, this is great. We love the office. We're so proud of you. And I was like, it was so intense. And then the guy pulling the curtain was the nicest guy ever.
但我走过走廊时，所有我以前共事过的人都说，嘿，这太棒了。我们很喜欢《办公室》。我们为你感到骄傲。我就觉得，这太强烈了。然后那个拉开幕布的人是史上最好的人。
And he was like, we're all so proud of you. Go out there and have a great time. And I blacked out, literally don't remember anything until I was standing in the seat. And Conan was already shaking my hand and he saw that I was having a panic attack. And he was like, don't worry, buddy, it's gonna be great. And pushed me into the chair.
他说，我们都为你感到骄傲。上台去，玩得开心。我当时脑子一片空白，真的什么都不记得了，直到我站在座位上。柯南已经在跟我握手了，他看出我正在恐慌发作，
And that's how I was. Wow. Cut to Kimmel says repeatedly that you and Arnett are two of the best, if not the best talk show guests in the history of- Oh, that's very nice. Of showbiz. Yeah.
他就说，别担心，伙计，会很棒的，然后把我推到了椅子上。事情就是这样。哇。切到吉米·坎摩尔多次说你和阿奈特是——如果不是史上最优秀的——绝对是史上最优秀的脱口秀嘉宾之一——哦，这太客气了。演艺界。对。
No, I think it's just I'm so happy to be humiliated for Kimmel any time he wants. I think the lowest was I dressed as a shrimp for something and I don't know what it was, but I was a shrimp. I dressed as a shrimp. On his show. Yeah.
不，我觉得这只是因为只要吉米想，我随时都非常乐意为他出丑。我觉得最惨的一次是我为了某个节目扮成了一只虾，我都不记得是为了什么了，但我当时就是一只虾。我扮成了一只虾。在他的节目上。对。
I was in a skin tight Spider-Man outfit once out in the Hollywood, out in front of the man's shop. Oh, yeah, on Hollywood Boulevard. Oh, I remember that. He loved, well, you guys were, you guys, I mean, those are pretty heady days, especially back then when you guys, when you moved up there and you and Kimmel lived
我有一次在好莱坞、在男士服装店门前穿着紧身的蜘蛛侠服装。哦，对，在好莱坞大道上。哦，我记得那个。他很喜欢，好吧，你们当时，你们，我是说，那是非常意气风发的日子，特别是当你们搬到那里，你和吉米住在
directly across the street from each other for a number of years. That was some fun times. Oh my God, the absolute best. Honestly, it's the thing we miss most about LA. It was the hardest decision because leaving, leaving those guys, leaving you guys was, it was really, really hard.
马路正对面好几年的时候。那真是一段有趣的时光。哦天哪，绝对是最棒的。说实话，这是我们对洛杉矶最怀念的事情。这是最艰难的决定，因为离开，离开那些家伙，离开你们，这真的、真的太难了。
Yeah. Now, speaking of traveling around and stuff, it's gotta be so tough that you and Emily being as busy as two people could ever be, I mean, if you wanted to be working nonstop, you both could be, but you seem to both decide not to be working at the same time as much as you can avoid it.
对。说到到处旅行这些事，你和艾米莉作为两个能有多忙就有多忙的人，一定非常艰难吧，我的意思是，如果你们想马不停蹄地工作，你们俩都可以做到，但你们似乎都决定尽量避开同时工作，只要能避免的话。
So that you can be with the kids and play mom or dad on the other person's set. You just kind of take turns, is that right? Yeah, we do the best we can to take turns. It's been, it was going pretty well until COVID because that just pushed everything back. So we had this whole plan. She was gonna do this, this amazing show
这样你们就能陪着孩子们，在对方的剧组里扮演妈妈或爸爸的角色。你们基本上就是轮流来，是这样吗？对，我们尽最大努力轮流照顾家庭。挺好的，在新冠疫情之前一直进行得挺顺利的，因为那把所有计划都打乱了。所以我们当时有个完整的计划。她要拍这部
that just came out the English. It's one of the best things I've seen in a long, long time if you haven't seen it. And she shot that in Spain. And I was doing Jack Ryan for two years straight because we shot two seasons back to back. And we took it. Which is also incredible.
刚刚上映的精彩剧集《英格兰人》。如果你还没看的话，这是我好久好久以来看过最棒的东西之一。她在西班牙拍摄了这部剧。而我连续拍了两年的《杰克·瑞恩》，因为我们背靠背拍了两季。我们接了。这也是一部令人难以置信的剧。
I mean, that's gotta be such a difficult shoot. No kidding. I mean, Jesus, God, it's a lot. Yeah, exhausting. It was crazy. I mean, definitely shooting, I think we were the second production back after COVID. I think it was Mission Impossible and us.
我是说，那样的拍摄一定非常艰难。真的吗。我是说，天呐，上帝啊，工作量太大了。对，筋疲力尽。太疯狂了。我是说，绝对是拍摄，我想我们是疫情后复工的第二个剧组。好像是《碟中谍》和我们。
And so you have 350 people showing up very courageously to work and saying we're gonna get back to work. And we were in nine countries in season three during COVID and all that travel. And then season four, I think we were in five more countries. And so it was nuts. I mean, it's so much fun. And I have such a great time playing the role.
所以有350个人非常勇敢地来上班，说我们要复工了。我们在第三季疫情期间去了九个国家，经历了所有的奔波。然后第四季，我想我们又去了五个国家。所以太疯狂了。我是说，真的非常有趣。而且我扮演这个角色也非常开心。
But yeah, I mean, shooting that is a, it's a whole different thing from being behind the desk for 10 years. Yeah, I mean, don't you miss that a nice predictable air-conditioned sitcom on a stage in Burbank? Oh yeah. Just LED lights, nothing changes. Yeah.
但是，拍摄那个过程和在办公桌后坐10年完全是两码事。对，我是说，难道你不会怀念那种在伯班克演播室里、nice又预测得到的空调情景喜剧吗？哦，是的。只有LED灯，什么都不会变。对。
Granddad, fucking cool your slippers for a second. We're talking to people who are out in the world. Craft service table over there, got you a dressing room in the stage. Like you go to craft service unless they've served cardboard and almonds. You're not going there. Hey, Krazy, it was such a departure though for you
老爹，快冷静一下你的拖鞋吧。我们在跟那些在现实世界里奔波的人说话。那边有剧组餐饮服务台，在演播室里给你准备了化妆间。除非他们提供的是纸板和杏仁，否则你才不会去那样的剧组餐呢。嘿，克雷兹，不过这对你来说真的是一个很大的转型，
truly actually kind of on what Jason was saying. Like you, first of all, I gotta say, one of the great things about spending, you know, the last couple of years about being at home a lot and whatever, one of the good things was catching up on a lot of things. And there were so many big pockets of the office
其实也挺符合杰森刚才所说的。就像你，首先我得说，过去几年花了很多时间待在家里等等，其中一件好事就是补看了很多作品。有很多《办公室》的精彩片段，
that I didn't see at the time. And I talked about it with Carell when we had him on. I never fully appreciated. And I watched it with my kids. My older kids, Archie and Abel just wanted to watch. That's all they wanted to watch. All of it, every single episode. We watched all the way through.
我在它热播时并没有看。我和当他来上节目时的卡瑞尔聊过这个。我以前从未完全领略过它的魅力。我和我的孩子们一起看。我的大孩子阿奇和阿贝尔只想看这个。他们只想看这个。全部，每一集。我们从头看到尾。
And I never, I feel like I never really got a chance to say back then when you were doing it. And we talked a lot at that time, you know, when you were doing the show, we spent so much time together. I never got a chance to say, how fucking great you were on that show. How funny, how in the zone you were,
我从来没有，我觉得我当年在拍的时候从来没有机会说出来。我们当时聊了很多，你知道的，当你拍这部剧的时候，我们花了那么多时间在一起。我从来没有机会说，你在那部剧里表现得该死的有多棒。多么搞笑，你是多么地进入状态，
how just dialed in you were a man. Honestly, it was, it's really, really, really good. And it lives forever. That is so nice. Super small and subtle too. Like, and that was like what, you hadn't done a tonnish it before that, right? No, I was a waiter.
你是多么地专注，老兄。说实话，这真的很棒、很棒、很棒。而且它会永远流传下去。这太贴心了。而且超级低调细腻。就像是，那是，你之前没拍过太多东西，对吧？没有，我以前是个服务员。
Yeah, I was gonna say, tell us how you got it. Yeah. No, that guys, that coming from you guys, that means so much to me. Really, it really does. I don't think Sean really agreed. I just said it should come, shouldn't mean a lot. John, tell me how you got the part for people
对，我正想说，告诉我们你是怎么得到这个角色的。对。不，伙计们，从你们嘴里说出来，这对意义重大。真的，真的意义重大。我觉得肖恩其实不太同意。我刚只是说它应该、不应该意义重大。约翰，告诉我是怎么得到这个角色的，对于那些像我一样不知道的人来说，
that don't know like me, like, what was that like? Was it offered? Did you have to read for it? I love this. Oh yeah, I definitely had to read for it. I was, I thought you were saying my question. No, no, no, no. No, I really was waiting tables.
那是什么样的体验？是直接给你的吗？你得去试镜吗？我喜欢这个。哦，对，我绝对得去试镜。我，我还以为你在回答我的问题。不，不，不，不。我真的在端盘子。
I hadn't done hardly anything. And I had done a couple of commercials and I got a manager. Jason, you played a waiter once, right? Sorry. Sorry. Paid a waiter, paid a waiter once. Had you seen the British office before you read for it?
我几乎什么都没做过。我拍过几个广告，然后找了个经纪人。杰森，你以前演过服务员，对吧？抱歉。抱歉。演过服务员，演过一次服务员。你在试镜英国版《办公室》之前看过吗？
Oh yeah, I was a huge fan, huge fan of that. And so waiting tables, I'm watching the black DVD of the office when it came to America. I remember it came in that black case and it was just, it was amazing. Went to a record store and picked it up. No, so I was such a huge fan of that and they called, I'll never forget actually,
哦，是的，我是它的超级粉丝，超级粉丝。所以当我在端盘子时，我正在看美国版《办公室》的黑色DVD。我记得它是用那个黑色盒子装着的，简直太棒了。去唱片店买的。不，所以我真的是个超级粉丝，然后他们打电话来，我永远不会忘记，
they called and said, would you ever come in to read for this show? And I said, great. And I had actually been out in LA testing for things that I didn't get. And I met Alison Jones who, The great Alison Jones. Cast your show, Arrested and cast our show.
他们打电话问，你愿意来为这个剧试镜吗？我说，太好了。我当时其实一直在洛杉矶试镜那些我没拿到的角色。我遇到了艾莉森·琼斯，
And she said, it's so nice to meet you. I have something coming called the office, look out for it. And I said, okay, great. And they called me and they said, will you come in for the part of Dwight? And I remember, Yeah, I'm waiting tables.
伟大的艾莉森·琼斯。选角导演，负责《发展受阻》和我们的剧。她说，很高兴见到你。我手头有个叫《办公室》的剧要上了，关注一下。我说，好的，太好了。然后他们打电话给我，说，你愿意来试道格的角色的镜吗？我记得，
Yeah, I'm coming in. No, I said no. I literally knew the show so well. I said, and my manager think, no, he thought I was insane. And I said, if I'm gonna do it, I wanna put my best foot forward. And he said, you know,
对，我在端盘子。对，我要去。不，我拒绝了。我对这部剧太熟悉了。我说，而且我的经纪人觉得，不，他觉得我疯了。我说，如果我要演，我想展现出我最好的一面。他说，你知道，
they're not very happy about this. They might not call again. I said, I would just rather not ruin my chance by doing that role. And then like six weeks later, they called and they said, can you come in for the role of Jim? And I said, sure.
他们对这个不太高兴。他们可能不会再打电话来了。我说，我宁愿不通过那种表现来毁掉我的机会。然后大概六周后，他们打电话说，你能来试吉姆的角色吗？我说，当然。
So I read for that. And then I remember I tested in New York first at 30 Rock. I was terrified. I was literally shaking. And there were seven dudes that looked exactly like me. Like all gyms just sitting on a bench. And each one after one went in and auditioned
所以我去试了那个。然后我记得我先在纽约30号洛克菲勒中心试镜。我吓坏了。我当时真的在发抖。有七个长得跟我一模一样的小伙子。就像一群吉姆坐在长椅上。每个人进去试镜后
and probably had a great time. I heard tons of laughter. Sure. The worst though. It was just me. It was just me waiting. And the casting director came out and goes, so we're just gonna take a quick lunch for an hour.
大概都玩得很开心。我听到了一阵阵大笑。当然。不过最糟的是。就剩我了。就剩我在那儿等。选角导演出来说，我们要去吃个午饭，休息一个小时。
So we'll come, we'll get to you when we're back. And I said, oh, just one more. Ooh, one more, one more. No? Okay. Waiting is so nerve wracking. So everybody leaves. Everybody came back with whatever the sweet greens was back then.
等我们回来再轮到你。我说，哦，就差一个吗？哦，就一个，就一个？不行？好吧。等待真是太煎熬了。然后所有人都走了。所有人都带着当时那些甜绿（Sweetgreen）沙拉回来了。
And I watched everybody come in and out like hundreds of people. And then this guy sat across from me and he said, are you nervous? And I said, no, you either get these things or you don't. But what I'm really nervous for is whoever's making the show because it is such a perfect show and Americans have a way of just ruining every good show
我看着成百上千的人进进出出。然后这家伙坐在我对面，问我，你紧张吗？我说，不，这种事要么能拿到，要么拿不到。但我真正紧张的是制作这部剧的人，因为这是一部如此完美的剧，而美国人有一种魔力，能把英国出品的每一部好剧
that comes out of the UK. And he goes, well, I'm Greg Daniels. I'll sure as hell try not to do that. And I went, oh, God. And Greg Daniels created the American office for people who don't know. Created the show. Yeah, he was.
都给毁了。他说，嗯，我是格雷格·丹尼尔斯。我一定会拼尽全力不让那种事发生的。我说，哦，天哪。格雷格·丹尼尔斯，不了解的人都知道，他创作了美国版《办公室》。他是这部剧的创作者。对，他就是。
Oh my God. The good news is he claims that it was one of the reasons I got the part because when I walked into the room, not out, they were laughing. It's a real Jim thing to say, by the way. That's what I'm talking about. You know, it's perfect.
哦，天哪。好消息是，他声称这是我得到这个角色的原因之一，因为当我走进房间时——不是出来——他们在笑。顺便说一句，这真是一个很“吉姆”的回答。这就是我要说的。你知道，这太完美了。
No, when I walked in, everyone was laughing and it wasn't laughing with you. It was laughing at, just pointing and laughing at how stupid I was. Oh my God. And when I did it, Greg said, you got the part because honesty is the best policy. And I remember that.
不，当我走进去的时候，每个人都在笑，不是在跟你一起笑。是在嘲笑，指着我笑我有多蠢。哦，天哪。当我表演完后，格雷格说，你得到了这个角色，因为诚实是上策。我一直记着这句话。
I remember that. And I was like, sure, man. Oh, great. Did they give it to you in the room? No. No, I then went to LA and tested. I remember I flew with Jim Gaffigan. Yeah.
我记着呢。当时我想，好吧，老兄。太棒了。他们当场就把角色给你了吗？没有。不，我后来去了洛杉矶复试。我记得我和吉姆·加菲根一起飞去的。对。
Bob Odenkirk, they were both testing for Michael Scott. And I remember they split up the New York kids and the LA kids. And so the New York kids went first and everybody left. And I was the last person in the New York group. And I didn't know what to do and all these LA kids were going in and they were testing.
鲍勃·奥登科克，他们俩都在试迈克尔·斯科特的角色。我记得他们把纽约的小孩和洛杉矶的小孩分开了。所以纽约的小孩先上，大家都走了。我是纽约组最后一个。我不知道该怎么办，所有这些洛杉矶的小孩都在进去复试。
And I'd been there probably five or six hours. And I finally just said, oh my God, they forgot to send me home. So I walked onto the set, the producers, they actually shot on the set of the show. They had already built a version of the set. Up in the valley there. Yeah, it was, well, we moved to Chandler Valley.
我在那儿大概呆了五六个小时。最后我终于忍不住说，天哪，他们忘了叫我回家了。于是我走进片场，制片人们其实是在剧中的那个片场拍的。他们已经在那里搭建了一个片场版本。就在山谷那边。对，那是，哦对了，我们搬到了钱德勒谷。
We started in Culver City. There was like a Culver City thing. Wow. But I went up and I said, I think you forgot to send me home. I'm gonna leave now. And from behind like a wall, you heard somebody go, no, no, no, no, no, no, don't do that.
我们一开始是在卡尔弗城。当时有点像卡尔弗城的那种感觉。哇。但我就走过去说，我觉得你们忘了叫我要回家了。我要走了。结果从一堵墙后面，你听到有人喊，不，不，不，不，不，别那样。
Don't do that. Give us 30 more minutes. And I said, okay. And in walked this girl. And I literally took one look this girl. And I said, oh, that's the person who gets the part. If I could ever read with her, I'd have one shot at this show.
别那样。再给我们30分钟。我说，好吧。然后走进来一个女孩。我简直看了这个女孩一眼。然后我说，哦，这就是那个得到角色的人。如果我能和她对词，我在这部剧里就有一线生机了。
And it was Jenna Fisher. I knew she was gonna get the role as soon as she walked in the room. Wow. And then we, they said, we just want you to read with one other person. And I said, who? And they were like, Jenna Fisher.
那就是珍娜·费舍尔。她一走进房间，我就知道她会得到这个角色。哇。然后我们，他们说，我们只想让你和另一个人对词。我说，谁？他们说，珍娜·费舍尔。
And I went, yes. Cause I thought if she, if I at least get to read with her, I'll have a shot and we read together. And I remember it was, as we walked out, I turned to her and I said to her, you're gonna get this part. And she goes, oh my God, I thought you would get this part.
我当时就说，太好了。因为我想如果她，如果我至少能和她对词，我就有机会了，然后我们一起对词。我记得那是，当我们走出去时，我转向她对她说，你会得到这个角色的。她说，哦，天哪，我还以为你会得到这个角色呢。
And it's very sweet when we both got the part as we both tell the story, it's true. The first thing I did was jump on my couch and scream. And then the second thing I said was who's playing Pam? And they said, this girl named Jenna Fisher. And I said, yes. Wow, isn't that great? Cause then you could do something.
当我们俩都讲起这个故事时，我们俩都得到了这个角色，这真的很甜，而且是真的。我做的第一件事就是跳到沙发上尖叫。然后我说的第二件事是谁在演帕姆？他们说，一个叫珍娜·费舍尔的女孩。我说，太棒了。哇，是不是很棒？因为这样你就可以做点什么了。
That's a story, that's amazing. Yeah. And we will be right back. SmartLess is brought to you in part by Viori Clothing, a new perspective on performance apparel. The product is incredibly versatile. It can be used for just about any activity like running, training, swimming, yoga,
这真是一个惊人的故事。对的。我们马上回来。《SmartLess》部分赞助商为 Viori Clothing，表演服装的新视角。这款产品功能极其多样。几乎可以用于任何活动，比如跑步、训练、游泳、瑜伽，
but also great for lounging or weekend errands too. Everything is designed to work out and but doesn't look or feel like it. So freaking comfortable you will want to wear it all the time. Seriously, it's more comfortable than whatever you're wearing right now. Like I can see you.
但也很适合日常闲逛或周末跑腿。每一件服装的设计都是为了运动而打造，但看起来和穿起来都不像运动服。舒服到爆，你会想一直穿著它。说真的，它比你现在身上穿的任何东西都要舒服。就像我能看到你一样。
You don't think I can, but I can see it like Diane and Houston, that's a wonderful blouse. I'm not judging you. You would probably look better in a Viori shirt or something. And you could just keep driving to where I know you're not supposed to be going, but you're going. Ed in New Jersey, you don't need to wear khakis every single day.
你觉得我看不到，但我能看到，就像休斯顿的黛安，那件衬衫真漂亮。我可不是在评判你。你穿 Viori 的衬衫或者别的什么可能会更好看。你可以继续开车去那个我知道你不该去但你正在去的地方。新泽西州的艾德，你其实不需要每天都穿卡其裤。
Like just you can put on Viori pants or Viori shorts. Nobody's going to think differently of you. And in fact, they're going to think better of you. Viori is an investment in your happiness. For our listeners, they're offering 20% off your first purchase. Get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet
就像你可以穿 Viori 的裤子或 Viori 的短裤一样。没人会因此对你有异样的看法。事实上，他们会更看得起你。Viori 是对你幸福的一项投资。对于我们的听众，他们提供首次购物八折优惠。去买一些地球上最舒适、最多功能的服装吧
at Viori.com slash smartlist. That's V-U-O-R-I dot com slash smartlist. Now only will you receive 20% off your first purchase, but enjoy free shipping on any US orders over $75 and free returns. Go to Viori.com slash smartlist and discover the versatility of Viori clothing. This episode is brought to you in part by Visible.
网址是 Viori.com 斜杠 smartlist。也就是 V-U-O-R-I 点 com 斜杠 smartlist。你不仅可以享受首次购物八折优惠，还能享受美国境内满 75 美元免运费以及免费退货服务。快去 Viori.com 斜杠 smartlist，探索 Viori 服装的百搭魅力吧。本期节目部分赞助商为 Visible。
You don't need your mom to help you dial your phone or order takeout on your phone. You shouldn't need her to save on your wireless phone plan either. Visible offers their best rate all on one line, not four lines, not three, not even two, just a one line wireless plan with unlimited data for $30 a month, taxes and fees included, all powered by Verizon.
你不需要妈妈帮你在手机上拨号或点外卖。你也不该需要她来帮你的无线手机套餐省钱。Visible 在一条线路上提供他们的最佳资费，不是四条线路，不是三条，甚至不是两条，仅仅是一条每月 30 美元的无线套餐，包含无限流量，税费全包，全部由 Verizon 提供支持。
It's smarter, it's simpler, and you get Visible's very best rate without a family plan. Switch today at Visible.com and get $20 off your first month when you use code smartlist20. That's smartlist20, a special offer for smartlist listeners. Offer ends March 31. New activation and code required for data management prices. Learn more at Visible.com.
它更智能，更简单，而且无需家庭套餐即可享受 Visible 的最佳资费。今天就切换到 Visible.com，使用优惠码 smartlist20，首月立减 20 美元。即 smartlist20，这是为 smartlist 听众提供的特别优惠。优惠于 3 月 31 日结束。数据管理价格需要新的激活和优惠码。了解更多请访问 Visible.com。
Additional terms apply. And now, back to the show. Willie, you have a similar experience when you read for Arrested, right? You remember that when you left when we walked out? We walked out. Well, I actually involves rain. Yeah, that's what I mean.
适用其他条款。现在，回到节目中来。威利，你当年去试镜《发展受阻》时也有过类似的经历，对吧？你还记得你离开时我们走出去的情景吗？我们走出去的时候。哦，其实那次下雨了。对，我是指那个。
Yeah, and I flew out to LA as well, and I was super sick. And I gave one of those auditions in New York when I read for it. I was like, whatever. I just kind of did it. And then they called, and they were like, you got to come out to LA, but you have to sign your test deal before you go.
对，我也飞到了洛杉矶，而且病得非常厉害。我在纽约试镜的时候就是那种态度。我想，随便吧。我就那么演了一下。然后他们打电话来，说你得来洛杉矶，但你得在去之前签好试镜合约。
And Prince Potter kept calling me, going my manager. Peter. And I go, oh, Peter. Yeah, and they kept going, I know, sweet Pete. And they go, you got to sign your thing. And he's like, they keep calling. And I go, hey, man, if they're so excited about me calling, why don't you renegotiate?
而普林斯·波特一直打电话给我，说我的经纪人。彼得。我说，哦，彼得。对，他们一直说，我知道，亲爱的彼得。他们说，你得把合同签了。他说，他们一直在打电话。我说，嘿，伙计，如果他们这么渴望我出演，你为什么不重新谈判呢？
Because they obviously want me to do this. So I said that at first, and I was kind of joking. But I fly out as me and Tony Hale. And Tony and I go out and I read for, I was there all weekend. And we worked with the Russo brothers who are now of Marvel fame. And then, and with Mitch Hurwitz, whom I just spoke to about an hour ago.
因为他们显然想让我演这个。所以我一开始这么说的时候，其实是在开玩笑。但我飞过去了，我和托尼·海尔一起。托尼和我一起去试镜，我在那待了整个周末。我们和现在以漫威闻名的罗素兄弟合作。然后，还有米奇·赫维茨，我大约一个小时前刚跟他通过话。
And they go, you got to go and read. It was me and Rainn Wilson. And God, who is the other? Do you remember? French Stewart? No, he had already done it. But somebody else, they had a bunch of like good guys and guys who had been working.
然后他们说，你得去读剧本。当时是我和雷恩·威尔逊。天哪，还有谁是另一个？你还记得吗？弗伦奇·斯图尔特？不，他已经试过镜了。但还有别人，他们有一堆优秀的演员和一直在工作的演员。
Rainn was still sitting, you went in before. So yeah, but a bunch of guys, Rainn had already done six feet under, like he had a real career going. And I was a fucking zero. And so we go in and I read and I come back out. And then the other guy came out and then Mitch followed him out and said, you got the part, you got the part. And I look over and I see Rainn still in the waiting room
雷恩当时还坐着，你先进去的。所以，是的，但有一群人，雷恩当时已经演过《六尺之下》了，他有着真正的职业生涯。而我他妈的就是个零。所以我们进去试镜，然后我出来了。然后另一个人出来了，接着米奇跟着他出来说，你拿到角色了，你拿到角色了。我转头一看，看到雷恩还在候诊室里
right there. Still running aside. And I've been that guy. That's why, John, when you're talking about being and waiting and then going to lunch or whatever, it's such a, already it's such a vulnerable position when you go out and you're putting it all out of the line and you want it. And I see him there and I've been in that position
就坐在那儿。还在背台词。我也曾是那个人。这就是为什么，约翰，当你谈到在等待然后去吃午饭或干别的什么时，那种感觉太，本身就是一个非常脆弱的处境，当你走出去把一切都押上并且你渴望得到它时。我看到他坐在那儿，而我曾经处于那种处境
so many times. And I just went to Mitch. I went, oh, no, no, please. And then I go, please, please, please, please. That guy's Rainn Wilson's right over there. Hasn't even read yet. Hasn't even read. They didn't even.
太多次了。我直接走到米奇跟前。我说，哦，不，不，求你了。然后我说，求求你，求求你，求求你，求求你。那家伙雷恩·威尔逊就在那边。甚至都还没试镜呢。甚至都还没试镜。他们甚至没有……
You were like, sorry, did my manager get to you about the renegotiation? Is it more? Did you talk to Peter Principato? Everybody followed out of the room, walked right past Rainn. They were done. But the good news is, about a month later,
你当时就像是，抱歉，我的经纪人联系你谈重新谈判的事了吗？片酬更高吗？你跟彼得·普林斯波托聊过吗？每个人都从房间里走出来，直接从雷恩身边走过。他们已经结束了。但好消息是，大约一个月后，
he reads for the office. It was like a year later, he reads for the office. And would have been unavailable. Just so you know, I personally believe, Arrested is, I think, my favorite show. I think it's my favorite show. No, it's true. Stop, Sean.
他去为《办公室》试镜了。那大概是一年之后，他去为《办公室》试镜了。而且本来会没档期的。顺便告诉你们，我个人认为，《发展受阻》是，我觉得是我最喜欢的剧。我觉得它是我最喜欢的剧。不，真的。停下，肖恩。
No, I remember... No, Sean's never seen it. Yeah, I know. I know, Sean. You've seen too, Sean. You've said you've seen too. Two episodes, yeah. It's fantastic.
不，我记得……不，肖恩从来没看过。对，我知道。我知道，肖恩。你也看过，肖恩。你说过你也看过的。两集，对吧。太棒了。
It's the best show I've ever seen. Those were great ones. No, but I remember when that show came on, it was such a big deal, because the office had come out, the British one, and that level of comedy was untouched. And then you guys came out with this whole other lane that was so good.
这是我看过最好的剧。那些真的很棒。不，但我记得当那部剧开播时，引起了极大的轰动，因为《办公室》已经播出了，英国版的，那种水平的喜剧简直是前所未有。然后你们推出了另一个全新的方向，而且非常棒。
And I just remember thinking, if I could be on a show that good, that has the confidence to... My favorite thing was how you guys brought jokes back at the end of an episode that you had barely touched on at the beginning. But you guys were that good, if not better, and people were actually watching your show.
我当时就想，如果我也能参演一部那么优秀的剧，一部有自信去……我最喜欢的一点是，你们如何在剧集结尾时带回那些在开头只稍微提及过的笑话。但你们就是那么优秀，甚至更好，而且人们真的在看你们的剧。
It stayed on for what, 10 years? You guys were a big hit. And I remember, you know what's weird? I just mentioned Janine Graffalo. She had sent Amy these, she had these tapes of the office that she brought up before. Like right around the time
它播了多久，10年？你们大获成功。我记得，你知道最怪的是什么吗？我刚刚提到珍妮·加法洛。她曾给过艾米这些，她带了以前看过的《办公室》磁带过来。就在差不多
they were about to start airing them on BBC America when Jason and I started watching, and I'd seen these tapes, and I was like, holy fuck, we'd already done the pilot. But I was talking to, I was like, this show is fucking, and it seemed like one.
他们准备在 BBC America 上播出这些磁带的时候，我和杰森开始看，我当时看过这些磁带，我就想，他妈的太神了，我们当时连试镜都拍完了。但我当时在跟人聊，我就觉得，这剧他妈的，而且感觉像是一部。
And then we started watching all these episodes, and we were obsessed with it. We were studying it. And then it was like, I remember them saying, at the time, actually, we thought that we were gonna maybe get canceled, Arrested Development,
然后我们开始看所有这些剧集，我们对它着迷了。我们在研究它。然后就像是，我记得他们当时说，实际上，我们当时以为我们可能会被取消，《发展受阻》
the entire time we were on the air. And like week to week. And we had been on the air for six months or something, and they were starting to put together the office, and Peter Prince Botto, my manager, said, hey, Allison Jones wants to know, if Arrested falls apart, would you come in, would you ever consider going in for the office?
在我们播出的整个期间都是如此。而且是一周接着一周。我们已经播出了六个月左右，他们开始筹备《办公室》了，皮特·普林斯波托，我的经纪人说，嘿，艾莉森·琼斯想知道，如果《发展受阻》黄了，你愿意来试镜吗，你会考虑去为《办公室》试镜吗？
I don't know if I ever told you that. For Jim. For the part of Jim and Pam. Oh my God. They were gonna make them into one character. Oh my God. Yeah. Just to save a little money,
我不知道我有没有跟你说过这个。为了吉姆的角色。为了吉姆和帕姆的角色。哦，天哪。他们打算把他们合成一个角色。哦，天哪。对。为了省点钱，
they're just a wig away. And they're gonna call them jam. Yeah, they're gonna call them jam. God, that makes sense. Well, there goes my spin-off. There's a lot. And I said, yeah, anyway, we made that pilot.
他们只需要一个假发就行了。他们打算叫他们“杰姆”（Jam）。对，他们打算叫他们“杰姆”。天哪，这倒说得通。好吧，我的衍生剧泡汤了。有很多。我说，好吧，不管怎样，我们拍了那个试镜。
Jim. That was, wow. Yeah, we made that pilot. That's why they won't, that's why they won't do a reunion, because my idea was jam, and they'd already done it. Hey, John, I have another,
吉姆。那是，哇。对，我们拍了那个试镜。这就是为什么他们不，这就是为什么他们不肯搞重聚，因为我的想法是“杰姆”，而他们已经演过了。嘿，约翰，我还有一个，
we'll be right back after this. Yeah, I have another question coming right back from the rest of the development rewatch podcast. Get us back on track. I wanna know of all the stuff that you're doing, because you are so now prolific as a director, and everybody is celebrating you in that way, and rightfully so,
我们稍后马上回来。对，我还有另一个问题，紧接着《发展受阻》重看播客而来。把我们拉回正题。我想知道在你在做的所有事情中，因为你现在作为一名导演高产得惊人，每个人都在以此方式赞誉你，这是理所应当的，
because you just are incredible. Do you have a goal of a film or a type of film that you really wanna conquer, that you haven't conquered yet, either like a genre or a specific story, anything in particular? Me, mom and son together, and I was going, please say musical,
因为你实在太不可思议了。你有没有给自己设定一个电影或某种类型的电影的目标，是你真的很想去征服，但还没征服的，比如某种类型或是特定的故事，有什么特别的吗？我和妈妈和儿子在一起，我当时一直在想，快说音乐剧，
musical comedy, musical comedy. Musical comedy. You know, the truth is, like I said, I never knew that I would have the opportunity to be a director, so I said I'm gonna do this. Just ask another question, now that you are.
音乐喜剧，音乐喜剧。音乐喜剧。你知道，事实是，就像我说的，我从没想过自己会有机会成为一名导演，所以我当时说我要去做这个。再问个问题吧，既然你现在已经是了。
Okay, copy. Copy. Fuck, I'm sorry. Let me just redo that, sorry. Let me throw this tissue away. No more tears, no more tears. I think you should remake the producers and put Sean in there as Gene Wilder.
好的，收到。收到。操，对不起。让我重来一次，抱歉。让我把这张纸巾扔掉。没有眼泪了，没有眼泪了。我觉得你应该翻拍《制作人》，让肖恩在里面演吉恩·怀尔德。
And I'll play Zero Mastel. There you go. Be honest, I can't wait Sean. I can't wait to see Good Night Oscar. Can't wait. Oh, that's so sweet. Thank you. Thank you.
而我来演泽罗·莫斯特尔。这就对了。说实话，肖恩，我等不及了。我等不及要看《晚安，奥斯卡》了。等不及了。哦，太甜了。谢谢。谢谢。
Look, he knows it's April. Look at this. We'll all go together. At the Barbarasco Theater. What is it? The Barbarasco, yes. Barbar, the Vinnie Barbarino. The Vinnie Barbarino Theater.
看，他知道现在是四月。看看这个。我们一起去。在巴尔巴斯科剧院。叫什么？巴尔巴斯科，对。巴尔，那个文尼·巴尔巴里诺。文尼·巴尔巴里诺剧院。
Has any show received more consistent press on a lean-in than this fucking Good Night Oscar? This thing better open. Let me tell you something. They better be fucking good now. You shit the bed during previews. No, so no specific, like, oh my God, I have this in my back pocket.
有没有哪部剧在开演前的宣传造势上比这部他妈的《晚安，奥斯卡》更稳定？这东西最好能大获成功。我跟你讲。最好他妈的现在就很棒。你们在预演时演砸了。不，所以没有什么特定的，比如，哦，天哪，我心里有这个压箱底的宝贝。
I don't care if it takes 20 years to make. I have this passionate story I want to tell. No, the way it goes for me is I fall in love with something and an idea that, and I just do exactly that. So this idea that I had for imaginary friends, I never thought I would do sort of a comparable movie would be like E.T. or something like that.
我不在乎花20年去拍它。我有一个想要讲述的充满激情的全心故事。不，我的方式通常是我爱上某样东西和一个点子，然后我就直接那样做。所以对于我为《神秘朋友》构思的这个点子，我从没想过我会拍一部类似《E.T.》之类可比拟的电影。
It's sort of a, and I never thought I'd do something like that. Certainly never thought I'd do genre at all. Didn't think, I could never watch horror movies, ever. I was so scared to watch horror movies, and so when I directed a horror movie, that was terrible. John, remember when we went to see I Am Legend? You ain't any...
这有点像，我从没想过拍那样的电影。当然也从没想过拍类型片。不觉得，我从来不敢看恐怖片，一次都没有。我太害怕看恐怖片了，所以当我执导了一部恐怖片时，那感觉太糟糕了。约翰，还记得我们去看《我是传奇》的时候吗？你根本没有……
Oh my God. And The Dark Knight came on. Oh my God. Oh no. What happened? What? Poor John. We just kept doing it over, and over, and over.
哦，天哪。然后《黑暗骑士》的预告放出来了。哦，天哪。哦，不。怎么了？什么？可怜的约翰。我们一直在重复，重复，再重复。
Cause that guy was the star of the show. That guy. No, but Will, do you remember we sat in this IMAX, and all of a sudden Will and I, again, were in this tear of just, you know, big action movies? You guys just burning afternoons, is that what it was? I mean... Just trying to get to dinner somehow?
因为那家伙是剧中的明星。那家伙。不，但是威利，你还记得我们坐在IMAX影院里，然后威利和我，再次陷入了那种，你知道的，狂看大动作片的狂热中吗？你们只是在虚度下午时光，是这样吗？我是说……只是想方设法去吃晚饭？
Oh my God. No, but Will, do you remember they played the first 10 minutes of The Dark Knight? I was about to say that. And we went, oh my God, oh my God. We've heard about this where they like switch a movie to test the audience. We're a test audience.
哦，天哪。不，但是威利，你还记得他们播放了《黑暗骑士》的前10分钟吗？我正要说这个。然后我们说，哦，天哪，哦，天哪。我们听说过这种事，他们会播放一部电影来测试观众。我们是试映观众。
And then it stopped after 10 minutes. And it went... I don't... That was fucking crazy for that. What do you mean they stopped the movie after 10 minutes? They stopped the actual... They literally showed the opening of The Dark Knight.
然后10分钟后它就停了。然后它变成了……我不知道……那感觉他妈的太疯狂了。你什么意思，他们10分钟后就把电影停了？他们真的停了……他们字面意思上放映了《黑暗骑士》的开场。
The whole thing is like a special thing tied to I Am Legend. But it didn't even say like this preview, it just started. Oh, that's... And we were like, oh my God, we're in a test. We're in a test. At first we didn't even know it was Dark Knight
整段就像是和《我是传奇》绑定的特别内容。但它甚至没有说这是预告片，直接就开始了。哦，那是……我们当时想，哦，天哪，我们在参加测试。我们在参加测试。一开始我们甚至不知道那是《黑暗骑士》
because you don't know it. And we're like, what the fuck is going on? And then we're like, oh shit, they're going to show the fucking movie. And then the Joker came on screen and we were like, oh my God. It was wild. And then...
因为你根本不知道。然后我们在想，这他妈是怎么回事？接着我们想，哦操，他们要放那部他妈的电影了。然后小丑出现在银幕上，我们俩都觉得，哦，天哪。太疯狂了。然后……
And we would do that fucking months to each other out of the blue just... Wild. I like that. I remember Amy hating it, Will. Do you remember? She'd go, guys, stop. She's talking.
我们就会冷不防地对彼此重复那句混账话……太疯狂了。我喜欢那样。我记得艾米很讨厌那个，威利。你还记得吗？她会说，伙计们，住手。她在说话。
And we were like... Shit. She hated it so much. You starting to sniff out any talent there with the eight and the six year olds? They want to act or direct or sing or anything like that, like mom and dad? They went through phases of it,
然后我们说……操。她讨厌极了。你有没有开始在那群八岁和六岁的小孩身上发掘出什么天赋？他们想像爸爸妈妈一样演戏、当导演、唱歌或者做点别的吗？他们经历过这样的阶段，
but I don't think either of them right now are wanting to do it. Would you let them? If they said they want to. I don't think they know that I'm an actor. So they're thinking I'm an accountant. Are they... Do you think they're going to be tall?
但我觉得他们俩现在都不想做这行。你会让他们做吗？如果他们说他们想的话。我觉得他们不知道我是个演员。所以他们以为我是个会计。他们……你觉得他们会长得很高吗？
Oh yeah, Hazel's very tall. Why is she? But it's not so tall, but yeah, Hazel's very tall. Just all things. But John's family, his parents are both really tall. His brothers are really... I'm the shortest. He's the shortest of his family, he's six, four.
哦，会啊，黑兹尔（Hazel）非常高。为什么她会？虽然不是特别高，但对，黑兹尔确实很高。各种事情吧。但约翰的家里，他父母其实都非常高。他的兄弟们真的……我是最矮的。他在家里是最矮的，他有六英尺四英寸。
Everybody is huge. If you ever want to... Anytime I spend time around John's family, I'm always like, fuck, man, I feel short. And I usually feel tall, especially around you two idiots. I feel like a really a person of substance. And then, because tall people are better. And so then, and I know I'm going to get a lot of pushback
每个人都巨大。如果你想……每当我跟约翰的家人待在一起时，我总是想，操，老兄，我觉得自己好矮。而且我通常觉得自己挺高的，尤其是跟你们两个笨蛋在一起时。我觉得自己是个真正有分量的人。然后呢，因为高个子更好。所以然后，我知道我会遭到很多反驳
on that, but John, as it turns out, was at the time for many years, John, what's the stat about your birth weight? Oh, I was the biggest baby in Boston, I think for... I was 11 pounds, 12 ounces. Good God, that's three children. Yeah, it was three children. And you were the last one? Yeah, I was the last one.
针对这一点，但约翰，事实证明，当年连续好多年，约翰，你出生时体重的那个数据是多少？哦，我是波斯顿最大的婴儿，我想持续了……我有11磅12盎司（约10.7斤）。天啊，那相当于三个孩子。对，就是三个孩子。你是最后一个？对，我是最后一个。
I'll never forget the story, Will loves the story. My mom went to a doctor's appointment and was with a doctor and a nurse walked by, a gentleman walked by and literally looked like he was in a horror movie. And he said to my mom, he goes, I was there. And she goes, excuse me? And he goes, I was there when you gave birth to that baby.
我永远不会忘记这个故事，威尔最喜欢这个故事。我妈去预约看医生，跟一个医生在一起时有个护士走过去，有个男的走过去，看起来简直像是从恐怖电影里出来的。他对、我妈说，他说，我在场。我妈说，什么？他说，你生那个孩子的时候我在场。
And my mom goes, well, I have three kids. And he went, no, you're a big one. But this guy was scarred for life. And then he went, and then he went, whaaaaa! I love that story, I can't get over it. That's really funny. Yeah, I probably wasn't the biggest baby in Boston.
我妈说，好吧，我有三个孩子。然后他来了一句，不，你生的是个大块头。但这家伙留下了终身阴影。然后他说，然后他来了一句，哇啊啊！我太喜欢这个故事了，简直挥之不去。这真的太逗了。对，我可能不是波斯顿最大的婴儿。
I was probably the biggest baby at that hospital for a while. But yeah. That's really funny. I was there. I was there. He was sliding in, shuffling like a zombie. He says, Krazy, fuck, it's so great to see you, dude. Thank you for coming and doing this, man.
我大概是那个医院一段时间里最大的婴儿。不过对。这真的太好笑了。我在场。我在场。他滑着走进来，像僵尸一样拖着步子。他说，克拉兹，操，见到你太棒了，老兄。谢谢你来做客，伙计。
This was so awesome. Thank you guys. I miss you, man, I miss you so much. When's the in-person stuff again? How long is it? So you're there for another eight weeks, then you're going to be in New York. And then I'll be in New York indefinitely. You know what that'll time out to?
这太棒了。谢谢你们。我想你们，伙计，我太想你们了。线下见面又是什时候来着？有多久？所以你在那儿还要待八周，然后你要去纽约。然后我就会无限期地待在纽约。你知道那会赶上什么吗？
It'll time out to carpooling to Sean Hayes' Broadway show playing at the Velasco. By the way, if you guys come for opening night, let's all go together. Let's all go together. Done. Done. Let's all go together.
那会赶上拼车去肖恩·海耶斯（Sean Hayes）在维拉斯科剧院上演的百老汇演出。顺便说一句，如果你们来看首演夜，我们一起去吧。我们一起去吧。一言为定。一言为定。我们一起去吧。
I would love that. I can't. That'll be really fun. And honestly, Sean, congratulations. That's amazing. Thanks, man. It's been about 15 years in the making. Wow.
我太乐意了。我可不行。那一定会非常有趣。老实说，肖恩，祝贺你。太棒了。谢谢，老兄。这筹备了大约15年呢。哇。
The reviews are off the chart. This is going to take everybody. This is going to be a smash at obviously. Well, thank you. Thank you. Thank you. Okay. But anyway, Johnny, it's so good to see you.
评价好得不得了。这绝对会吸引所有人。显然这会大获成功的。好吧，谢谢。谢谢。谢谢。好吧。不过不管怎样，约翰尼，见到你太好了。
I haven't seen you in so long. Please let's get together when you come back. I would love it. And thank you guys. This was wonderful to hang out again. It's been too long. I miss you guys. Sean, love you, buddy.
我好久没见你了。你回来后我们一定要聚聚。我求之不得。谢谢你们伙计们。能再次聚在一起真是太棒了。太久没见了。我很想念你们。肖恩，爱你的，伙计。
I miss you too. Love you, man. All right, guys. Thanks. Bye, Johnny. Eliminium. Oh, nice. He knows how to slam it.
我也想你。爱你，老兄。好了，伙计们。谢谢。再见，约翰尼。Eliminium。哦，不错。他知道怎么“砰”地挂断。
He knew. He couldn't wait to slam it. He's a listener. He couldn't wait to slam it. That's such a... He's a true listener. I mean, he is a listener. As you know, he's texted...
他懂的。他迫不及待想挂断了。他是个忠实听众。他迫不及待地想挂断。这太……他是个真正的听众。我是说，他真的是个听众。如你所知，他发短信给……
Jason, he's texted you too. How much he likes listening to the show. And I tried to put it together for a while. I obviously knew he was coming on for a while. And we were just trying to time it out for a couple months. That was a good surprise. Wait, he was really supposed to go on the day of or after Emily? I'm pretty sure it was the day after or two days after.
杰森，他也发短信给你了。说他有多喜欢听这个节目。我试着筹备了一段时间。我显然早就知道他要来上节目了。我们只是试着把时间错开几个月。那真是一个惊喜。等等，他本来应该是跟埃米莉同一天来还是在她之后？我敢肯定是她之后的第二天或者两天后。
Wow. That would have been wild. And that's why you guys... And you guys were after... We had Emily on the show after the record. And when she left the show, we were talking about it. And you guys were, we got to get John on it. And I was like, Jesus fucking Christ.
哇。那可太疯狂了。这就是为什么你们……你们在……我们录制完节目后让埃米莉上了节目。当她离开节目时，我们在讨论这个。然后你们说，我们得让约翰来。当时我就想，耶稣基督。
I know. I kept going, no, I know. And you knew it. You knew it the whole time. Thanks. What a great guy. This really sucks. He doesn't live in LA anymore.
我知道。我一直说，不，我知道。你心知肚明。你从头到尾都知道。谢谢。多好的人啊。这真的很逊。他不在LA住喽。
I know it does. It changed everything. I know. Why don't we just move to New York? I know. He lives in New York, right? Right. Yeah.
我知道很逊。这改变了一切。我知道。我们为什么不直接搬去纽约？我知道。他住在纽约，对吧？对。对。
Yeah. Yeah. But anyway, we've talked about the three of us about and fantasized about all of us just living there full time again. I know I used to live there for over 20 years. I know. I know. Do you miss it, Will?
对。对。但不管怎样，我们三个以前经常讨论并幻想过我们所有人重新搬回那里全职生活。我知道我以前在那里住了20多年。我知道。我知道。威尔，你想念那里吗？
I do. I did. When I first sold my apartment, it was like five, God, coming up on six years ago. And I was like, no, I'm just like, so LA now I really, I really miss it. I do. It's hard to. What about even just for friendships? Like it'd be like, guys are terrible about maintaining friendships, right?
我想。我以前想。当我第一次卖掉我的公寓时，大约是五年前，天哪，快六年了。当时我想，不，我现在太像洛杉矶人了，我真的，我真的很想念它。我是。这很难。哪怕只是为了维持友谊呢？就像，大家在维护友谊这方面都很糟糕，对吧？
I will speak for myself. I just feel like, well, it'll just, we'll just pick it up right where we left off. And for the most part, that's true. But I mean, maybe in our last third half quarter of our lives, we'll just throw it all away and just do friendships. No, no career. We'll do that with the retire. For sure.
我只代表我自己。我只是觉得，好吧，这很简单，我们会从离开的地方继续。大部分情况下，确实如此。但我的意思是，也许在我们生命的最后三分之一、一半、四分之一时，我们会把一切都抛诸脑后，只去经营友情。不，不要事业。我们在退休时会那样做。肯定的。
But that's one of the great things about when you are in New York and, you know, obviously Krasnay talked so much back then in the day. We would, yeah, we would burn afternoons and go to see movies and stuff. But when you're in New York, you kind of do that more than we do in LA. We were so sequestered. You walk everywhere. In Los Angeles. And the three of us, obviously, because the weekends we spend time together or whatever
但当你在纽约时，这就是一大好处，你知道的，显然克拉兹过去经常那样做。我们过去常常，是的，我们会消磨整个下午，去看电影之类的。但当你在纽约时，你做这种事的频率比我们在洛杉矶要高。我们太孤立了。你到处走走。在洛杉矶。而我们三个，显然，因为周末我们在一起度过或者别的什么
and Jason, we play golf. Like if it wasn't for that, we wouldn't see each other. Right. You know, it's funny. You guys know Mike O'Malley and your friends are them and my old friend. And I remember him once saying, like, when you, people getting mad, like that you don't hang out anymore. And he used to always say, yeah, life happens.
还有杰森，我们打高尔夫。要不是因为这些，我们根本见不到对方。对。你知道，这很有趣。你们知道迈克·奥马利（Mike O'Malley）以及你们是他们的朋友，还有我的老朋友。我记得他曾经说过，当人们生气时，比如生气你们不再一起出去玩了。他过去常常说，是的，生活就是这样。
And then when you see each other, you pick back up and you don't go like, hey, why don't we hang out? You don't get into that shit. You just go, hey, I love you. And like, here we go. You pick it back up. But like, but, but, but here's the thing, like a marriage, friendships are also work. Yeah.
然后当你见到彼此，你们重新接上头，不会去说，嘿，为什么我们不一起出去玩？你们不会纠结那些破事。你们只会说，嘿，我爱你。然后，我们开始吧。你们重新开始了。但是，但是，但是，关键是，就像婚姻一样，友谊也是需要经营的。对。
Right. You have to put the effort in in order to receive it back. So I think if you think of it that way, that's how I think of it. Yeah. You think of our friendship is a lot of work. Too much. Good to know. Good to know.
对吧？你必须付出努力才能得到回报。所以我想如果你这样想的话，我是这么想的。对。你觉得我们的友谊需要付出很多努力。太多了。知道了。知道了。
I feel like you guys are staring at my box here. Well, we were when you were flossing your teeth. Hi. Hi, girl. So, but Johnny, we love him. We do love him. And it was great. And I'm so happy that we've now had.
我觉得你们俩一直盯着我的方框看呢。好吧，当你在用牙线剔牙时我们确实在看。嗨。嗨，女孩。所以，但约翰尼，我们爱他。我们确实爱他。这太棒了。我很高兴我们现在有了。
I was thinking also, two of our friends, but certainly two guys that I used to spend, you know, a lot of time with and, and still do in various, you know, cause we were, like we were just saying life kind of happens. But two guys who had different times in my life, I've considered to be, it almost sounds patronizing to say little brothers. It's just because they're younger than me, Kraz and Bradley have begun on to become these great directors. And so is this other guy we're looking at, Jason Bateman.
我还在想，我们的两个朋友，但绝对是我以前花很多时间在一起的两个家伙，现在也是，因为正如我们所说，生活就是这样。但在我人生的不同阶段，我有过两个被我视为什么的家伙，说他们是小弟弟听起来几乎有点居高临下。这只是因为他们比我年轻，克拉兹和布拉德利已经成为了不起的导演。我们正在看的另一个人也是，杰森·贝特曼。
And so was Jay. But yeah. Also younger than you. Please. Looking. Sorry. Let me finish. Oh, that's true.
还有杰伊。不过是的。也比你年轻。拜托。长相。抱歉。让我说完。哦，也对。
Go ahead. I guess that's fair. That's, that's cause you have all that dirty hair. You know, that was great to talk to John. Very, very difficult for the interview to be over because, you know, at the end of it, you got to say bye, you know. Yeah. Bye.
说吧。我猜这很公平。那、那是因为你有一头脏乱的头发。你知道，能和约翰谈话真是太棒了。要结束采访真的非常非常难，因为你知道，到了最后，你得说再见，你知道的。对。再见。
So let's just, let's just make it real this time, you know, it's hard to say bye to John. I'm trying to make it real and also bye. So bye. Give your best crying bye right now. Soft, soft, bye, soft, cry, bye, cry, bye, will, or Sean, what's your best cry by? That was it. Oh, will. Hi.
所以让我们这一次就来真的吧，你知道的，跟约翰说再见很难。我正努力来真的，同时也说再见。所以再见。现在给出你最好的哭腔再见。温柔、温柔的再见，温柔的哭，再见，哭，再见，威尔，或者肖恩，你最好的哭腔再见是什么样的？刚才那个就是。哦，威尔。嗨。
Here's mine. Ready? Yeah. Oh, God, I had a little bit of vomit in it too. So I guess they'll let us know, they'll, they'll let us know which one they want to go with. My availability is, thank you. You swallowed that bye. Fuck.
这是我的。准备好了吗？对。哦，天哪，里面还带了一点呕吐物。所以我想他们会让我们知道，他们会让我们知道他们想用哪一个。我的时间很充裕，谢谢。你把那个“再见”给咽回去了。操。
That was a good one. Smart. Smart. Smart. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Bennett Barbaco, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjurf. SmartLess. Your next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to
那个不错。聪明。聪明。聪明。SmartLess由班奈特·巴巴科（Bennett Barbaco）、迈克尔·格兰特·特里（Michael Grant Terry）和罗布·阿姆茹夫（Rob Armjurf）100%有机且手工制作。SmartLess。你的下一期节目将在一个星期后发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你可以在
it right now early on Amazon Music or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
亚马逊音乐上抢先收听，或者通过订阅苹果播客或汪达尔（Wondry）应用上的Wondry Plus抢先收听并免广告。本期节目暂无评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可留下评论。